[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
yeah
let the horns play
[Music]
yeah
let the horns play
let's get it more Incognito the MC let's
get it
what's going on how y'all doing Sunday
Sunday Sunday a little tired today but
getting my energy up good to see y'all
in this that little Galvatron that's my
man's I was busting heads up in the Halo
what's going on y'all getting the door
we've been before okay Boosie what's
going on y'all want y'all want a 16.
pop not what's up regulator what's going
on Kyle give me a train always trade but
I'm gonna be real like I'm happy they
had Jimmy I ain't gonna lie like what
they did to keep Jimmy with the
insurance you know what I'm saying so
that was a small move that took a lot of
Pride and shout out to Jimmy it was
there for two minutes yo what's going on
I popped out don't want my 16 eyes
bro what's up man slimy long oh a lot of
knowledge fan in here let's get this W
yes let's do that punty what's going on
you can't
[Music]
of course the legendary OG Bay Area
Gerald Mack in a building I see you
salute I see the videos giving
inspiration wondering touch my guy
what's going on the midweek mix-up Lord
himself got that Lord gold up I
appreciate you brother it's fun playing
games with y'all yesterday you know what
I mean lives of privacy what's up
what's going on
[Music]
fun topics pixel [ __ ] what's up I see
you Mass all right can't say it like
soft said but salute black conflict Xbox
manpower to the people you know what I'm
saying
X Abbott oh he ready for competition
Abdullah new as what's up Texas lead
yeah
I see y'all regulated what's up that's
what I got salvation what's up Thomas
Laurel salute okay
[Music]
cause I need to focus up
I gotta Focus right now I'm sipping on
that probably support that strawberry
daiquiri the new new Texas what up y'all
I'm gonna need some Focus today it's one
of them days
[Music]
easy hold it down Zach what's up powder
5. yeah I need that poly I know what to
do I know what to do you know what I'm
saying go to advanced.com code I unload
on the checkout yeah I know what to do
yeah I definitely did take the focus
thing get the energy for the gym but
Focus for right now
a little sleepy
anyway enough of me rambling let me go
get that oh you need the power let me
get you the late brother
all the powder y'all know that hold on
get you the link let me put you in with
the connect right quick
as soon as y'all need that powder like
out of yeah I'm pushing P that's right
that's right I'll pushing that positive
P right there man GG go get that get
that 10 off right now I think we got a
mini fridge going on shout out
to the whole team
artists with everybody down with
Advanced GG I see y'all moving and
shaking you know what I'm saying look
man don't talk about man he moving that
other he moving that other if you want
that uncut you want that rule
South face you're gonna give me a
trouble just look at my bed he doing
what he do on his side of the block I'm
doing what I'm doing on my side of the
block outer the focus Advanced GT energy
let's go
yeah have fun with that Community all
right no doubt yeah shout the attic man
he'd be putting them together
he said you know why we damn force a
legend you didn't want to hear me talk
you know why we here let's go King uh
you on that King in them podcast all
right
on that note I guess I better go let me
go get cake let's just pause the legend
nobody hear me right there yo right here
Bill duh what's up Puckett Road what's
up
just wonder what what you wanna do I'm
on the Block I'm outside man I'm moving
things out here sitting podcasts you
already know what's up Isaac thank you
for the legend I'm saying show your boys
some love babe I woke up early to set
this up for y'all man what's my favorite
flavor gobble to um I like that sour you
know I like that sound that kind of
resonates you know what I'm saying they
got the watermelon flavor they got the
sour apple you know what I'm saying
Focus flavors oh grape is fight great go
get that grape right now I'm sipping on
the strawberry daiquiri you know what
I'm saying getting right see my energy
already up with the focus already
what's up
um
[Music]
Isaiah early with the place Xbox has no
games I just want
yo you actually got my surname right
okay okay Dallas man what's up just so
y'all know who's about to spit right now
it's one of the illest in the mic right
now the gaming we did our intros the
legendary Dallas Man level one gaming
the boy gets it poppin he gets bars and
I'ma probably let him talk cause I've
been talking I'm still talking to this
one I don't know but I'm gonna let him
get his balls off and then we're gonna
get a whole attic and pulled up
oh you're playing games so look attic
don't get up here King about to get in
here I'm not trying to get that uh gmca
whatever they doing with the music and
I'ma see y'all in a minute
and listen to the wonderful walls of
Dallas men that's in the chat this boy
is spit and spitting let's go
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
down look y'all messed up and turned me
to an animal and headers be swearing
ain't real but come to find out that
they really mechanical and yeah I'll be
using these rappers but that's all a
part of me being a cannibal and they say
I'm better than money because you can
Bank on me being accountable I know a
million rappers that don't want to be on
the song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and Snapple and making it flammable this
is that this is the Yoga Fire Flame they
think it's Arsen up in the apartment
they call it department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
the rains you just a Target when I'm in
the range I was the hardest to start
regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal I got you man
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell her Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers they don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all feel Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and Sample and making it flammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's Arsen up in the
apartment they call it department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting the rain you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless messaging people on
AIM check my vocals all on Twitter but
I'm anti-social or my city but I'm still
by Coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell her Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until the time to get this
show started so um
damn look y'all messed up and turned me
to an animal and headless be swearing
ain't real but come to find out that
they really mechanical and yeah I'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being a cannibal and they say
I'm better than money because you can
Bank on me being accountable I know a
million rappers that don't want to be on
a song with me that's understandable I
kill a beating they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and Snapple and making it flammable this
is that this is the Yoga Fire Flame they
think it's Arsen up in the apartment
they call a department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
them Reigns you just a Target when I'm
in the range I was the hardest to start
it regardless back weed with messaging
people don't aim check my vocals all on
Twitter but I'm anti-social know my city
but I'm still bicultural I got it
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell an Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers they don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and snapping and making it flammable
this is that this is the Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's Arsen up in the
apartment they call a department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting the rain you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless and people don't aim
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell her Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
damn look y'all messed up and turned me
to an animal and headers be swearing
ain't real but come to find out that
they really mechanical and yeah I'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being a cannibal and they say
I'm better than money because you can
Bank on me being accountable I know a
million rappers that don't want to be on
a song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddy and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you also Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and Snapple and making it flammable this
is
the Yoga Fire Flame they think it's
Arsen up in the apartment they call a
department and I get the blame still
I'll be running collecting the rain you
just a Target when I'm in the range I
was the hardest to start regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social lower my city but I'm still
by Coastal
[Music]
because it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy Krueger that's who
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
down look y'all messed up and turned me
to an animal and headers be swearing
ain't real but coming to find out that
they really mechanical and yeah I'll be
using these rappers but that's all a
part of me being a cannibal and they say
I'm better than money because you can
Bank on me being accountable I know a
million rappers that don't want to be on
a song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and Snapple and making it flammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's Arsen up in the
apartment they call a department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting them rain you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell an Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important to who I am uh what's
important is that you are pulling up to
the iron Lords podcast right now as we
speaking uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
down look You Oughta messed up and
turned me to an animal and headless be
swearing ain't real but come to find out
that they really mechanical and yeah
I'll be eating these rabbits but that's
all a part of me being a cannibal and
they say I'm better than money because
you can Bank on me being accountable I
know a million rappers that don't want
to be on a song with me that's
understandable I kill a beating they
wanna compare me to Freddie and Jason
I'd rather be Hannibal they'd be like
why use a video game just be original
y'all too Dramatical I know it's random
but I'm addicted to flipping and Sample
and making it flammable this is that
this is that Yoga Fire Flame they think
it's Arsen up in the apartment they call
a department and I get the blame still
I'll be running collecting the rains you
just to Target when I'm in the range I
was the hardest to start it regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my CD but I'm still by
Coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell her Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
and we are alive I Am Lord podcast Lord
Cognito here talking about the latest
with Advanced GG there's a lot of things
going on with the new product live let's
get right to it
so we got that Focus line y'all this is
that standard that's what we use right
now kind of our caffeine substitute and
what we usually do right now when we're
gaming we don't use coffee anymore we're
utilizing this focus on Deck number two
you already know it's my favorite right
here the energy line you already know
birthday cake one of my absolute
favorites completely delicious this is a
pre-workout equivalent and also doesn't
use beta Adeline so you don't get the
Jitters and stuff like that so it's
really good for that and then the new
new we got that hydration line y'all
this is really good for people who don't
like caffeine who want an electrolyte
substitute and it is really sugar-free
absolutely delicious so you got your
three choices once again you know Cog
love is sour you already know and we're
doing this right now so go get yourself
to advancedg.com use code iron Lord on a
checkout this is something I use all the
time got to support Advanced EG great
products if you want to get your workout
on even if you don't work out you're
just gaming you need that focus and
again the hydration in line for those
who don't want caffeine no sugar
electrolytes you're good to go lower
Cognito here iron Lord podcast peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
on the Lord today
if you got work on a Sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on the Lord's Day
[Music]
all right all right all right little mic
check right quick see the levels of this
OBS thing somebody talk to me real quick
hello hello hello yeah there you go
there you go how are you this fine day
yeah there we go again the levels right
all right here you hear you and we are
live welcome to the iron Lords podcast
LLC and also live on lordsofgaming.net
episode number 273. this is another
glorious Sunday we're back at the round
table on the Lord's date I'm very
excited about our special guest and
we've got Microsoft wanting competitions
with sodium
series as sales in Japan a potential
Xbox handheld and team ninja choosing
Game Pass to discuss so we gonna get
right into it
I want to introduce the Lord who not
only provides a refreshing and objective
new voice within our Gaming Community
but whose passion for Tech Trends
informative debate and pop culture
easily managed to keep it on the real
introducing the created host of the
ksati YouTube channel co-host of the
gaming Circle podcast and panelists of
the Prime Time gaming podcast
the Lord of slander regulation
fellow VR bredrich and world renowned
Captain keys of the Halo TV show
you see the resemblance y'all
live from Florida and finally making his
debut into the realm of the Lord my man
Lord K Asante how we doing sir okay I
can leave now I just need to record that
so every time I show up in a zoom
meeting that was right beforehand thank
you thank you this is amazing
I appreciate you having me this is
awesome man like as I said to you uh uh
in the DMS before I love this show I've
been watching this show for a long time
I'm here to represent you know oh
proud
your patience and the scheduling try to
work everything out and it had to go
there you know what I'm saying that
obviously you know we actually linked up
in real life when I was out there in
Florida when I went to gcx yeah that was
real cool
see that's what I respect kid like when
dudes pull up you know what I'm saying
like it's not just talking and like
dudes actually go to the events they go
outside to salute the ksati what you've
been playing brother what you've been
playing oh so that's a that's a that's a
very open-ended question and uh that may
start a debate for a long time but no uh
real quick as as a as uh I'm not sure
who coined the term I think either I was
either Jazz Cordon or it was pong soul
but they have coined the term and and I
I I basically feel myself diagnosed that
way I am a grazer oh at any given given
moment I'm playing maybe 18 different
things
and you kind of like bounce around like
you oh yeah I'm always bouncing now now
uh recently shout out to Lord sovereign
[Music]
deck all day baby like now what am I
playing what platform I'm playing that
changes but what Hardware am I playing
it on it's steam decks I've been just
steam deck for for a while uh let's see
you were you were like one of the first
that was super high off the steam deck
and you were giving me the breakdowns as
soon as the the specs came out and what
you were able to do with it so you
already had plans with it further than a
lot of them brother man I had plans with
that and I have the plan I have
beautiful plans with the old Logitech G
Class
you know but no I've been playing a
bunch of games you know I've been
playing a bunch of uh Nintendo games
with the kids you know um Mario Kart and
Mario Tennis and this and that I've been
getting into that metal hell singer love
that mental health singer I think it's
great you know I've been playing that
um believe it or not been spending far
too much time in
well uh death stranding
re-occupated Gamepad okay yes sir were
you slanderous at release and now that
it is
see I thought I was I played that game
when it first first came out and I
thought like initially you know and I
listened to a bunch of podcasts as well
I love the the introspective
conversations about what the game was
was it getting somewhere or was it the
journey to get somewhere and the more
you play the more you find out that it's
the traversal itself that's the game
that I thought was super interesting and
it was one of those weird things where
I'm like maybe one weird thing will
happen out of nowhere because it is a
Kojima game let's see how long I can go
and see if that happens like
10 hours later I'm still I'm still every
once in a while
it's fun it's fun you know they're down
they'll dance with the kids side to get
the games and grazing all over the place
you know what I'm saying salute and you
already know we got the Four Horsemen of
gaming those original logs around here
at the round table my co-host Nicole
Mouse my brother from another mother the
difficult game conqueror Lord of his own
world and the how of the young wolf my
man Lord addict of the attic show how we
doing sir doing pretty good uh you know
I played a lot of death loot this week
actually
I I I've been invading our mutual
friends on their worlds as Julianna and
then you know when I first started there
was a bunch of them there you know that
I could invade pretty equally but uh
yesterday it seems like they all turned
it off
you terrorizing them well it's because
because I played a lot of on the
PlayStation 5. so I know how to troll
people on that so like I know where
they're gonna move down with the beta
testers oh Lord
the the I actually played the game when
it came out but anyway
there's like these little things that
you could put for sanity grenades on
stuff and I know the way people usually
go about getting like to certain
rooftops and stuff so I'll put it like
right there beside an a a ledge and when
they go up it hits them off the map and
then they die automatically yeah what's
funny is like I do it like five or six
different Ledges and then like I'll just
see them it would just say you've been
connected disconnected from the host
they got tired of you terrorizing it
then because I'll just throw those up
and then I'll just go on a rooftop with
a sniper rifle or something and just
wait for them to go over those those
grenades there's an evil I see what
you're doing I see what you're doing so
it's been all def Loop nothing but def
Loop anything else
I played a little bit of Destiny too uh
that that's about all I I really haven't
had a whole lot of time this week for uh
gaming but I did put a lot of time and
death loop from Fall guys played a
couple games of uh
Fall Guy uh Fortnight this morning with
Bill oh Bill legendary epic games
that's what's up there's some weird
stuff on there now like you can yeah
they got these like buildings that if
they're Chrome you can phase through
them like Silver Surfer oh yeah not like
Silver Surf for like T2 oh like the
Terminator 2 like okay yeah because I
was saying more like the material seems
like more like yeah when you get the the
chromia
um you turn into a ball you can turn
into the the like you know how when T2
turned into the slime on the floor you
can turn into the slime on the floor and
move around you can jump out it is it
adds an extra layer and mechanic to the
game that is crazy and not to mention
like up until now the only way to get in
houses because if houses are built of
chroma you could face through the walls
yeah so you don't even have to go
through the front door the only way you
could go into a house currently is you
neither destroy a wall which is very
loud or you go through a door which is
very loud I'll be sitting there like
looking at the door because someone's
chasing me and then and then when I I
sense there's more of them there I just
face to the other wall and run like that
you know somebody TV I can hit ATV I
don't know if someone's got the not mine
I mean the YouTube I can hear a little
bit just slightly it's very very low
maybe the YouTube's coming through but
anyway it's been it and of course we
have the most technical gaming Lord the
solo gamer who lives for the single
player selfish experience and also the
soft stradamus the Lord of clarity and
Lord patreon of the iron bank my man
Lord solver play multiplayer games this
week what's going on yeah I know
yeah
we're getting back on that bike is uh
is difficult to say that
you did that guy I got my head caught
out there popped I was like yo that's
something yeah you know what it is you
know what's so different about how you
know I go back to that Kayla one hit or
two days you have your map and you
didn't really have too much in terms of
like changing things around or whatever
it was the map was what it was you
memorized the map you memorized where
the weapons are and that's how you kind
of started you got really good at it
right I was a big sniper rifle guy and I
go right for a sniper rifle and we did
you know anytime we did like blood goats
or anything like that and these Maps you
know again custom maps you could do
whatever you want everything changes and
the maps are so big that it's like it
every time out you can't really rely on
anything right you have you just have to
sort of adapt to the situation in a
moment yes and then so it's just
different right it's just different but
it was fun playing with the whole crew
playing with the community you guys
really came in there and really really
and really showed out so that was fun I
wish I could have stayed longer but uh
yeah man I mean it's funny because we
talk about all this stuff about Halo is
that yeah
there's nothing wrong with Halo except
the release Cadence of content right
beyond that Halo's fight to its core
right
is there
we said last week Halo is a fantastic
first person shooter it's a horrible
games as a service yeah it shouldn't
have been a game well and that was my
fear of going into it I was like when
you change it into something else you
have to understand that who you're who
the game has to be for and then also the
the release kid is because at that time
like one of the first things I said was
like hey man fortnite is out here like
monthly like weekly doing different
things so you have to be on that Cadence
if you want to stick with that and it's
just hard it's just hard maybe you know
they they need to figure that out and
maybe figuring it out means it's not
suited for that or maybe maybe they you
know they body up and then you know we
have you know they have 500 people
working on this game at some point who
knows so so we'll see
um I've been playing more AC Rogue on my
um on a steam deck that's an another
thing what's up Acro reminds you about
the limits of that style of Assassin's
Creed game as opposed to the the RPGs
right the RPGs immediately let you climb
anywhere and everywhere right it doesn't
matter where AC Rogue you have climbing
paths you have certain things
specifically you can climb on and you
can't just go up everything so
um that's different so my My Hope in
playing this right I'm enjoying it I'm
getting used to the limitations again
but my hope is that when we go into
Mirage next year they take some of that
stuff that they learn from the RPG ones
some of the stuff that they decided not
to pursue after Assassin's Creed one and
they mix all of that together to give us
like the perfect smaller stealth-based
Assassin's Creed I I don't know that
they're gonna do that because that's a
lot of work and you know and one thing
about you is it feels like a lot of
their games are like on a freaking
assembly line but um
My Hope Is that they really take all of
those things they didn't pursue in the
past more distilled stuff more of the
social stealth stuff and then
Incorporated with some of the freedom
that they give you in the RPGs to make
that that perfect Assassin's Creed game
that appeals to everybody right we'll
see we'll see but I'm excited for that
and the last thing big shout out to LA
Machina La Makita what's up baby
joining the 700 Club where he belongs
I'm sad that he is retiring because I
would love him to stick around as a DH
for a few more years and get that fake
bonds out of there oh oh you're coming
for kick oh wow
nah bronze bonds was great before the
juice well here we go
the moment Aaron judge hit 62 he's the
king oh man okay oh recipe you
[Music]
[Laughter]
knock knock another kid and he you know
the ryzen promotions
he did one of them
in Japan he knocked out the star MMA oh
man shout out to Floyd get in the bag
doing what he do yeah
right now he's out of pocket but anyway
and of course we have the Incredible
Hulk of this aka the excess baseball
gamer
the prophet of Xbox Swami King of the
statues who demands nothing less than
that premium experience and is the
leader of the fraud alert movement
beloved Lord King how we doing sir I
want to know at what point in time can I
get my general of the stop snitching
campaign add it to my name
General campaign okay and you know uh it
was just wild with it but we ain't gonna
go there uh Shakur Stevenson okay the uh
top rank is weirdo
on Friday
and they got that lead to the side at
work you know when you at work yeah like
wake up anyway
boom she called Stevenson in Top Rank
wanted to have a fight on a Friday so I
couldn't do a combat talk on a Friday
you know uh scheduling stuff you know
Cog has the last words and stuff like
that and you know we try to stay in line
with uh who who has what days on IOP but
what I don't like is uh you know them
switching up Premier fights on off days
weird days
it'll make Shakur Stevenson's ticket
sales and views
look miniscule because people aren't
used to those days a Friday being a
fight night or maybe for MMA or
something like that but not absolutely
not okay so no Friday no Friday Night
Fights no okay fair enough fair enough
but you've been playing what's the
difference between the day
he would rather play switch to listen to
me
baseball and combat talk back tobacco at
it let me download let me know you
download Saturdays it's traditional
fight nights yes you know um if you're a
bum you fighting on Friday nights and
Monday night fights yeah we know that so
to have somebody fight on a Friday night
and he's a premier ticket uh pull up
disrespectful and barbarum does that to
certain people of different Persuasions
but always
um yeah yeah
all right so he said this is what we're
doing
um
I was playing uh definitely I heard that
just came out
that a brand new game because it came to
a certain surface well you know I didn't
acknowledge it when it was in beta so
like oh so let's put another platform it
was a beta it was they they didn't get a
complete verdictions
actually the gold in the dish what is it
yeah okay so that is oh that's a
brilliant Edition
see the thing is uh there there's a
lacking there that game is lacking you
know I saw a digital Foundry shout out
to y'all for doing the job uh and
actually telling the truth for sometimes
you know some things anyway oh wow so
def flute was dope
um it's this game that I had uh
downloaded and it's called
um
and it's like it's like Doom right it
feels like back then it feels like
Wolfenstein or old Doom not new Doom no
okay you know old Doom like when it came
out and I like these these new companies
going back and revisiting 16-bit era and
giving us a proper 16-bit 60 frames per
second no drops no no frames missing
type of games
um I love the Metro vanias we we have
the animations and stuff like that
coming through so that it was a welcome
surprise when I went and I checked it
out I was like wow this this is a little
bit different and you know I play Halo I
really like like added I really didn't
have much time to do anything else I
played some fortnite this week he was
trying to get me into Fall Guys and I
said at it I have one hour today and I'm
not going to be distracted I love you
you can do more games on Fall Guys than
one Fortnight man and that talk that
tells the whole story right there
no doubt no doubt salute and then the
next time we play Fall Guy she's gonna
complain why he don't have any of the
cosplay
oh you missed out
he could be like soft send me send me
your money from the iron I mean they
need some of this
shirt you see the shirts
but somebody please get him one of these
I'm good
anyway sometimes things gotta get
snitched on sounds like you're infected
bruh
send me one of those actually speaking
of snitching right Cognito let's go oh
oh okay you're coming for me I know what
you're doing I know what you do because
I told on you
we're gonna get to it and of course
ninja himself did you know me look
cognitos right now to the rubber IOP not
tell you what you want to hear what you
need to hear that needs to be your name
for now
you get one week you get one week of
that that's it no every week it's just
such a ninja himself
I was like wow these dudes really did it
up for them
snitch again
you know since you say Jeff Groban the
report I hope they say the snitching
engine report
yo shout out to the hotel yo you don't
have fun with it it's just you're not
gonna be able to don't
talk about IOP with the snitching ninja
you know refrain to yourself is the
defining dude sneaky ninja
sneaking ninja
so yeah for me been rocking on Shop to
uh Mr Maddie plays had a great defining
Duke where um yeah man we talk about
what's going on in the industry had this
real the conclusion of the me and Mr
Maddie plays Yakuza like a dragon beef
was hilarious go check that out he had
his things to say the community was
dragging him but it was funny he stood
on his Square how he felt you know what
I'm saying kind of thing wrong Square
yeah a lot of people feel it's the wrong
square but I I had that heart to heart
with him you know because I know what
happened you know what it is okay it's
like you know when someone trying to
afford like you having fun you playing
your game and then the community trying
to force you out of what you doing to
make you do something else so you
already come in with the disposition
like oh this better be the hottest thing
in the world cause y'all stopping me
that was the dinking right exactly
that's right so I already know what part
of it is but he did have some good
always as to why he's not feeling
certain things in um right the grindy
aspects which I thought was legitimate
argument because it's a part and Persona
is not grinding oh that's true too
the argument that he had considering the
games he's been playing recently right
the trail series right I think his thing
is that when he went into this story and
I think paste the stories right Yakuza
stories in the past have their funny
side and they have their serious side
right and there is a delineation within
that right A lot of times the silly
stuff is Side Story stuff and it's not
really super incorporated into the main
story arc whereas like a dragon is a lot
different it's completely different it's
completely different like it's like
Ichiban himself is a different type of
character where comedy is kind of that's
cool
so I understand that integration with
Ichiban I understand how it's different
but coming from uh coming from core
Yakuza games yeah played which is only a
couple but he's played some of those the
few feeling is completely different yeah
yeah and I get that I get that I think I
was gonna say is that yeah because if
that if you played the series you came
up with that you he loved that right I
could see how someone could say you know
what this is culture shock like what are
they doing and I get that you know what
I'm saying but finish off I interrupt
you no no and then he made another great
point where it was just like usually
when you come into a series you're
you're most attached to the one that
brought you in of course and no matter
what so yeah it is that thing like those
old games brought him in yeah he's been
on a different type of RPG tip for for a
while now so it's jarring in and of
itself just to sort of switch to
something else and he just he he was
able to see the differences very
distinctly and he just something he
didn't like if he had come in with like
a dragon and a hadn't been playing so
many jrpgs up until now right because
he's a big Jr yeah so he might have felt
differently but I get it I still need to
play like a dragon
all I know is he's the only man's on
this Earth I've ever talked to that says
that you don't like that game yeah I
mean look it's not for everybody you
know what I'm saying you know this time
look I was I got I stole me for elderly
I was like the world was spoiled
okay when you go when you go on there
with that kind of mindset that you're
gonna hate something because you're
being made to play something I get that
but at the same time the quality of that
product speaks for itself
you don't give it a chance you don't
give a chance
he literally put to work I gotta give
him give it up you know at the end of
the day it's like not everything's for
everybody it's not for him it's all good
also shout out to define the ultimate
had an amazing fantasy football style um
episode it was it was hilarious we get
to pick uh teams what games we think is
going to come out for it's funny yeah
and then your little bets on the
metacritics hilarious go check that out
that's the ultimate for the patreon or
shout out to the last word he bought
this talk out challenge demon Joe pulled
up young boy is hilarious he fit right
in go check that out as far as games
with me finally death Loop like King
said man got a chance I waited I am glad
I know King's being disrespectful caller
beta but I am glad I waited because it's
like at the end of the day we do get the
extra stuff if they gave hair so I was
like ah it's not really a lot though
like the extra stuff you get I'm not
feeling happy at the end of the day it's
something it's not really a lot but um
they give you fries with your food and
that's not really a lot but I don't eat
fries so I guess I mean if if something
was missing and I get something extra
that means that other product was
incomplete
boys
I should have waited too because I went
and bought I'm like I'm gonna play this
man I played two hours you know how it
goes like it I I couldn't find time
afterwards it was like it was 60 bucks
oh hold on we got two merge purchases
gotta salute the record oh three hold on
put the crest up I know the name
situation you know I mean that was that
was that was Phil Dominus Maximus oh wow
you're going crazy after his own cup
listen they got the um the iron Lord
joint with all of us you know what I'm
saying that t-shirt up in oh I think
it's like at the dog
yeah then they got the Phil Dominus new
cup the new Phil Dominick's cup with
deceptor and all of that then somebody
copped the little man shot the little
man in Black yeah man no doubt salute to
you you know what I'm saying I had to
give it up right there doing what you do
so
anyways
[Laughter]
but uh yeah so I've been doing that um
definitely in Japan yeah he definitely
definitely thinking Japan we're gonna
get to that for playing that um attic
I've been playing that whoa long finally
took some time with that demo I took I
hit you up the first time when you
played it I was like still real he was
like hogged on that that's it that's it
yo graphically very impressive character
creative put you down here together like
I'm very impressed people of my
persuasion could be made in this
universe very accurately I have a very
accurate Mass Effect level
representation of Cognito inside whoa
long getting my Shaolin oil go ahead I
don't remember what my character even
looks like yeah I didn't get into the
camera
I'm from the astral chain I love you
Astro chain I love it yeah jrpgs but
sometimes just slapping a tone on the
same model is it sufficient to represent
meat you know what I'm saying I feel
like a lot of like the reason the
Japanese people have a problem with that
is because like I don't think they care
I don't know that sounds really good or
you get Barrett and that's a whole yeah
but we're gonna leave that alone but
um what I will say is the care and
attention to detail on that that's one
two the game like I love the different
like the water style each one has like a
different one support you know what I'm
saying the one I'm using is like a
magical type of class it's fast it's
fluid
um Elden ring
um they have a very seamless even though
it wasn't implemented in the business
it's like sekio yeah yes
and a little ghost of Shima Vibe because
some of the attacks when ghost people
someone will do that unblockable there's
that that red flashing light to let you
know yo what what oh Sacramento what
you're about to get hit with you either
better learn the counter or you better
roll get out and just get out the way
clear representation it means the vibe
it's just a nice vibe to it yeah it's
the first game that team ninjas ever
made that I can honestly say is on a
from software like this felt like that's
what it felt like it felt like from
himself yeah it felt like when you start
Elder ring and you know you get to that
little overlooking and you see what you
got to deal with you know and then for
me you Shaolin ninja the situation I'm
in now now I'm like yo now I get why
y'all love Elder ring the way I love you
because I'm like oh this is the elder
rig for me yeah you know what I'm saying
so I'm like okay this I like the ninja
magic yeah I like um the choices that
you have to take the options you want to
do like a fire and and stuff like that
if it's going to be defensive
I thought it was a from software game
and I I said I could have sworn I said
Team ninja when I loaded it up so I had
to back out again and then I went back
into it and I said it did and I said wow
yeah they really saw Eldon ring yeah
they was just like you know
probably not but you know um they really
wanted to change the direction of how
holiday games work and this is a vast
departure from what their games normally
are yeah shout out to roll along very
very impressed I I got a friend my video
about this game pass
shout out to us yeah shout out to us
hey
this is probably like one of the most
and one of the most impressive games
they've gotten in Game Pass in a while
yeah this we're gonna get out with you
what do you get to your topic
they just got deaf loot that's their
game I expected that you did yeah I
expected it last year
guess what happened to my expectations
anyway there we go so we're doing that
staying sharp on
um Tekken seven on my steam deck staying
sure I'm up in the dojo I've been up I
think I've been online are you feeling
these dudes with these theme decks it's
like three steam decks to two none of us
me and you don't have these things I
mean I don't need one either but it's
like it's like Mercedes-Benz owners
yeah we're a little bougie with it yeah
yeah yeah you feel like mercedes-benzies
let's see if we talking about this this
thing anymore
every time someone has made some form of
handheld I keep hearing the word oh this
is gonna kill the switch
about a year and a half ain't nobody
talking about it again see you focusing
on one argument
it's like one dude pissing him off
yeah give me a second yeah hold on uh we
have Lucius Augustus two dollars Super
Chat member for one year love playing
Halo with the Lords IOP stand up shout
out to Lucy thank you that was great and
we got four as a legend member for 34
months Lord bronze thank you so much
well well well looks like Sachin Adella
wants all the smoke Jim cataracts lion
Rhymes watch out on God and them Xbox is
the best box
fifth Lord remember for three months
Lord bronze sir shout out to the
birthday man Mr boo shout out to boom
sticks
today's the birthday
is is holding it down today for him yeah
put the question I gotta say uh I
apologize boom I try with all my heart
to make it to your show on Friday happy
birthday many many more uh a lot of
people were hit me and they didn't my
DMs this weekend uh telling me it was
their birthday so salute to everyone
because it was a lot of you guys uh
Happy Birthday Happy Birthday boom man
when the Legends in the community
uh yeah
for sure happy birthday to the man Mr
Boom without him I would not know about
King and the Lords and a thank you to
him no doubt yeah he's responsible for a
lot of people getting shot in the
community yeah for sure we got hargit to
me remember for one year shout out to
you sir five dollar Super Chat so look
to the Lords let's get to Jim crying
dance moves snitching lion riding yeah
bring it
[Laughter]
thank you
now we got free R Kelly five dollars
Super Chat hey good morning hope you
guys have a good day I ain't got much to
say on Sony domination today I'm too
busy playing Modern Warfare 2 Beta
you know and I gotta say this I I love
you cows
um the problem is you know your guys day
is a number
the money man said so you want
competition well let's do this then
we will get to that yeah
go ahead go ahead I was gonna say man
like you know hit us up when you get it
to the end of the generation you out on
what's that thing on hot house when
you're doing the half House
at the End of the generation it's Savage
bro continue yeah we got tons of each
team for ten dollars sup chat sup
Lawrence I'm here for one thing [ __ ]
stop snitching what happens if the
family stays in the family no Takashi in
here
so yeah well he's referring to the point
do the point okay the point there you go
there you go
so on the latest episode of defining
dude [ __ ] tells the story about how he
was unaware that I despised uh Friday or
Saturday nights when I would come over
and I my intention would be Halo some
wrestling
and I'd walk in and they'd be playing
yeah so the thing is this is where I got
a couple of hot who knows oh well that I
didn't he talked about I didn't know
this yes you did no I was thinking
he this is him choosing not to care
because I was the only dissenter
everybody over there would come and be
like okay make my man this way make my
character this way I'll walk in and be
like do whatever you want with him
not have any input I'd be like yo I'll
be in the other room playing Rolling
Thunder
oh I'll be playing PSP and nah man and
it was one of those things like they
probably had you kicking the doors open
first like since he died
yeah yeah so that was not about that
because the thing is that game again all
shout outs to them because you look at
that game and it was the most disgusting
looking thing you really needed to get
into it to understanding it and play it
but I just remember like the first time
going in I'm like all right let me give
this a chance the first time and they're
like yo put me up here on OverWatch or
whatever and I'm like up here and then
you look at the screen and it was a flat
surface and I'm like where is where are
the levels here I don't see where it's
up here is and I'm just like nah I'm
good let me play some of those I could
not so he knew full well that I despised
this game he just chose not to care I
chose not to get listen man you never
said
he just he chose to upstave after a
certain amount of time he just left the
reasons still having fun so maybe maybe
he's ignorance is having fun yeah that's
probably what it was
no doubts
hold on a second let me get this uh X
Del XD Melo seven five dollar super
chapters y'all be saving my ass on the
labor on a labor Sunday shout out to you
working on Sunday sir shout out to the
king Cog and the crew and
foundistas uh apologies for my bad
Portuguese I appreciate that
then we have Donald tackle five dollars
whoa long all right but Xbox eight cats
are dub because rise of the Ronin is
going to be a better team in the game it
is exclusive to PlayStation 5 shaking my
head
that's out in two years
no it literally said exclusive to places
oh no we know it's exclusive well it'd
be exclusive for a time period but we
don't know that it's better like they
pass stuff off to people then we're
gonna get the Gold Edition
[Laughter]
once again
having that kind of mindset we're going
to go from games like Persona to games
like that then we're gonna get
everything two years later you're like
don't don't Persona have a Gold Edition
[Laughter]
I'd rather play the game when it comes
out than get a goat I hear you I hear
you I hear you
ah and this is this is the cross I need
to Bear everybody oh here we go
let me play with your joystick two
dollar Super Chat speaking of whoa long
oh no hey yo I'd even catch that wow
I gotta put the eggplant in them
have you seen the picture the picture
yeah
I keep saying he right he or she but
when I reference him is she is
[Laughter]
part of me feels like was he
deliberately tried to sound suspect or
he just doing a Super Chat that sounded
suspects I think it's very purposeful
then we got Texas five dollar Super Chat
it's the Lord's day let's go Sacha
smoking on that gym snitch pack
that's gay violence sir
perpetuating gang culture Gay Culture
sir relax
stop snitching down the town that we had
we see anything else Papa
we could we caught up
that's right stop snitching he's getting
decision off
a little butt there we go I go on the
precinct with the shirt on
it'd be like really really really
do really do so now that we've got into
what the laws have been playing we got
to switch our Focus to the patient Lord
K Asanti his video game system history
his journey into content creation and of
course what led him to creating the
gaming Circle podcast and the chaosanti
YouTube channel so locanti what are some
of the first video game systems you had
and what got you in the game except
uh so I knew this is going the question
was gonna come up but
it's weird uh when you become an old
like I am yeah that question becomes uh
more difficult to answer every day um
let me see uh I would say probably the
first video game system itself yes must
have been
has to have been Nintendo like the NES
NES yeah you know I'm an 80s baby born
in 80 but
you're a young buck yeah
oh yeah yeah I just started the back
pain
early days yes yeah during during that
time you know as as it tends to be uh
you're young you don't have too much
money and even during that time maybe
parents don't see the value in consoles
so you know it was difficult getting
what you wanted until a little later
down the line so I think I think my
first actual official console that I got
to keep and we'll get into that first
console I got to keep was probably not
the NES but probably the Game Boy the
game boy that was the first one I got to
keep okay okay so we're talking the
tetris days
now now I will I'm sure I will start the
slander early but to me objectively oh
objectively okay the greatest game ever
made Tetris oh it'll be my favorite game
yeah yeah that's the greatest game I've
ever made okay this is probably because
next year a Tetris game will come out
and still sell out
the most perfect game made yes from the
music to conception to execution
yeah and I have to say that the the most
perfect version of Tetris
Tetris effect Tetris effects
is great Tetris effect in VR another
level mind blowing yeah yeah yo shout
out to Hustler motivated you know you go
oh for that senses yeah right though
gaming Todd Patrick is in there you know
what I'm saying Christopher everybody
listen Tetris sir
Felix oh yeah it was was Monumental for
his time and what what was it the pack
in for the Game Boy The Game Boy it was
the packing for the Game Boy yes it was
the packing for the Game Boy and I
played the living heck out of that thing
like like man you know and I think I've
seen some some articles recently not too
long ago about somebody that took it to
war or whatever and it like a Game Boy
got mortared or whatever and still it
comes back and it plays Tetris
yeah I saw the video I saw the video and
it was like it's all covered in like
like cemented like it was destroyed
because it was made for children and
Nintendo knew they had to build them
like Tonka trucks oh believe it or not
okay I'm learning that now like my two
kids were getting into that gaming realm
right now and as much as I'm like yeah
box
[Music]
you don't hand them a switch it ain't
going down yeah
talk about it so so you just have to
kind of regulate that hey you know we
all transition from period to period yes
the Nintendo period is what was good
right now
what I would tell you to do
um you know as as as the one that has
actually the earned in power oh here we
go right what I would tell you to do is
walk in there with a Wii U and said this
what this was before that was that
you know what so what they said to you
and we'll get into it we'll get into
where it all started but like I have all
the OG consoles like all almost all of
them all the OG officials so like I've
handled them like a Nintendo NES the
only thing they could play at the time I
think was balloon balloon time I think
it was okay okay oh that's what's up the
two of them you know and then we we
moved on to Genesis Genesis you know we
tried such a good daddy oh you know you
know
shout out to the homie shout out to the
homie ever born Saga my my kids love
Sonic
wow like Sonic is the game in my
household that's what I've been doing
I've been trying to get those nuts yeah
balloon fight yeah that's what's up no
doubt no doubts for their game boy that
was first so where did now you
transition to you know either console
wise Peace So yeah so okay so when I was
young and and and some of us some of us
who have these these uh uh upbringings
knows what uh originally West African
right yeah that comes with culture yeah
it has a certain certain way of being
yes and to make it to make it a a double
situation not only West African Ghanaian
oh God yes also also uh uh a half of my
family was Jehovah's Witness oh
so it made it difficult to you know oh
yeah you can't you can't have the
worldly possessions and violence in
these games that's right that's exactly
real quick that is Jehovah's Witness
part right yes yes but then the African
the West Africa
let me tell y'all back real quick sorry
about for those who don't know
with JW household like if you had the G
I know my friend right he had the J.R
like GI Joes and stuff like Transformers
and stuff and so they get them and then
take the weapons out the box
let me add a
a more Arrow to your to your quiver sir
let's go my birthday is December 25th oh
you're finished
bro you're finished bro not only do you
get no acknowledgment again no
slandering already we're just given the
reality
in the religion so that grew up in it no
birthdays No Holly no one so you go to
school everybody's like yo this is the
gifts I got it was my birthday and they
were like yeah okay excited what did you
get
needless to say I say all that to prime
the pump and say it's a little difficult
getting what you want absolutely when
that is your situation absolutely right
so so yeah so it ended up being so
initially so I lived all over I lived in
Europe uh most of my upbringing because
my parents uh I lived in the Netherlands
basically I most of my my years of being
raised were in Holland Amsterdam places
like that so so that's kind of dope
kind of dope so basically after
um and I think let me see the next
console After Game Boy so I moved to the
states I've been moving back and forth
so so I have to do a little thinking so
moved in in early early 90s and mother
my mom's lives in the Netherlands but my
dad lives in the states okay and moms
was like you know you call moms hey you
know how you doing this and that
maybe maybe hit me with that Nintendo
I would like this
so the first time and at that time of
course Mom and Dad divorced early on
it's a whole whole thing so a dad lives
in the states and I live with Dad so Mom
would send money to her sister who lives
in New York and then and at the time I
lived in New England Rhode Island at the
time this is early 90s okay so she would
then come visit me for the weekend bring
me the NES I'm just like
Escape that was the hookups
I think King knows where this is
I don't know about this let me go go
ahead go ahead so weekend comes it's
amazing happy and I know what's good so
I hide that in my room I don't care let
nobody see that it is what it is long
story short it ends up in the attic oh
no
and that's where it starts and once my
dad recognizes that I know it's in the
Attic then it disappears forever
[Music]
and I broke my heart when he told me
that and I couldn't break I couldn't say
that story I mean he has to tell his
truth and when he said I was like wow
no but you know what though you know
what I'll be honest with you all of
those experiences really got me to work
to where we are today I'm glad you said
so that's good you know all of it was
really good because what it did was so
early early on I was really into music I
love music I studied music in school I
was really I play a bunch of instruments
all of this right and music led me to
technology technology led me to games
yes and for some reason the world would
just never let me get get my game on
right so it became almost a mission of
my life yeah to be able to get my game
to be able and that's what got me where
I am today great [ __ ] brother so I'm
just like you know keep taking it away
from me that's what got me where I am
and again even though we would you know
we said when we said it was the harsh
realities of a kid not being able to
experience certain things that we wanted
you know what I'm saying it gave you
more of an appreciation where you were
able to have it and in defense of the
religion and culture and stuff like that
it made us focus on studying it made us
focus on education and you have an
appreciation for it so I do I definitely
want to say no no shade no shade on the
religion no shade although I wouldn't
consider myself I wouldn't call my um
count myself among their ranks you know
I've spent I've spent a lot because of
that that uh upbringing spent a lot of
time investigating religion yes and I
found appreciation and understanding for
all kinds of knowledge I can I can
really communicate you know my best
friends Muslim dude they cannot connect
real well we have great debates and you
know it's always great so no no no shade
on that absolutely my I just have one
take from it like um the fact that you
know you were given the the NES and it
you know mysteriously disappeared uh did
that play a hand in your level of
respect to your consoles that you still
hold to these day to this day because
um
with my own personal stuff I purchased
all of my stuff myself so anytime I hear
a story with people like oh my father
brought me this or my mother brought me
that that was not to be yeah The King
Family household was dead bro Corpus so
I had to go work for everything and I
had everything but
that's the reason why like you can look
in my background and see I have stuff
because I value everything I have yes
that's it that's true that's real
brother absolutely no you're absolutely
right King yeah uh what was it uh
somebody told me this weird uh thing
about what was it uh oh
um damn it what's what's the man's name
um uh Eddie Murphy yeah when he was when
he was coming up he won he couldn't
drink Cola when he was good he had no
money so what did he do when he got his
first million he built a room his whole
house bro built the room and put nothing
but coconut bro
these are the drivers right because
Eddie Murphy he put nothing but coconut
yeah
he had he had two rooms
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
yeah apparently it was a bet because
Richard probably a better black 100
Grand that you can't sing he's an old
word and he got up with Rick James and
he made the album literally I hate to I
hate to say it to y'all guys but y'all
gotta check the Spotify account he has
some new albums out there oh yeah
with Nicki Minaj
tremendous I love hearing these stories
and the upbringing so now you get the
passion for Tech you're going forward
you know what I'm saying so okay so yeah
real real quick so so what what ended up
happening with that whole situation was
basically so at the time I lived in the
states lived with my dad he took my my
my my uh Nintendo away all four reasons
right and it's not just that reason this
was the 90s you know yeah video games
rock your brain oh yeah yeah yeah you
know that kind of thing and what was my
favorite game it happened to be Mortal
Mortal Kombat
yes
yes
my dad would leave go to work sometimes
you know when when he's out and and I
come home from school or whatever and at
the time like he had and for the
children in the room he had a brother
word processor now
let's go
yell at my mom's not to get that I was
like yo we getting a computer B an
actual computer yeah no she's like I
don't need it I can just buy a word
processor no
in the head just a little screen
just that little strip the little strip
and then that's all they had and then
you just had to pray that that you
didn't make all these mistakes and then
the cool thing is that it would print
out the whole document at the end right
but it was Fitness crook that's right
that's right that's right but my my
dad's one had a few lines it wasn't just
straight dot matrix it was a little it
was a little a little thicker so we
would stop when you sell your Nintendo
so and one of the best things about this
brother the word processor is on the
install floppy disk which you like yeah
that's right that's right you could also
and and dad did not know this but of
course dad's uh son spoke the language
yeah so found that Tetris was also
playable
that was your hospital
I spent most of like I would say the the
early to mid 90s just playing Tetris on
the brother word practice he's like wow
he's so studious
did you was that pre-installed on there
or did you did the engineer things with
both the floppy comes with both the the
the the basically the startup sequence
for the mini OS that was right another
word processor and also had Tetris in it
okay and you know you're poking around
you'll you'll you'll start to notice a
trend yes I do a lot of breaking stuff
and I've noticed that because of that my
son is a little something I can't say
he breaks everything
so yeah that that's basically how I got
my Tetris fixed for quite some time
you'd go to school and you'd you'd pass
by the computer room and the CRTs are
like this big yeah and you know you know
and then you'd pass by and you'd stop
and your mouth is gate why because what
is that on the screen it happens to be a
screensaver of I think it was
Wolfenstein 3D
screensavers yeah so I was always kind
of in the gaming sphere but the game the
game boy OG Game Boy was was my first
real real like console oh for a while
until I until I moved out of the states
no doubt so so for me it's funny it's
been you share very similar gaming
Histories on some level like I think the
when it's kind of like the first console
that you bought with your old money I
think is a real significant thing right
so I wanted to yes yeah prior to all
because everything you could only do who
in moderation is very limited to access
to what you could do my out was my dad
because they my mama my dad was
separated so I would just go he would
take the arcades he got Nico so like Dad
was like she would get mad
with this stuff so my question is now
when do you get to that point where it's
like okay okay Santi this is my console
my money I get to do what I want surely
surely before I got to my console there
was one other console that came in the
mix that really changed the equation
let's talk about it so so at some point
I was living in the States this was the
90s this was the early 90s I think I was
like 12 13 and then and then I moved
back because I didn't want to live with
my dad anymore it was a little whole
thing move back live with my mother
right and for a short amount of time I
lived there for just about a short
amount of time but I wanted to go to
college I want to go to high school
college this and that so my mom was like
okay well you can go live with it with
your with your uncle but before I did
that I spent I'd say a couple a couple
years or so in in in the Netherlands
with my mother and at that time like uh
my um she had remarried stepbrother my
cousin was all the room a house full of
boys and a little one Emma so I would
say like four boys four five four boys
in the house so we kept working on mom
kept working on Mom and as you know
money's tight but we still did what we
had to do no doubt you know and and she
bought she brought home she bought the
PlayStation one with the demo list
[Music]
absolutely and that and I will say at
that time she had been strayed from the
okay straightforter okay God I gotta go
oh yeah
yeah she's separate from the flocks
you know mom's always been that way he's
always been have my best interest at
heart
let's get to your demo this because you
got to demo this in the house and and
for a lot of you guys that don't know
you are happy as hell when you got a
demo this oh all right so you had the
one with Jumping Jack Flash what what
did you have on your demo this do you
remember I mean battle arena
you know you know what it is
crazy bro that 3D generation bro the
three generations it started off with
that Sony a bit of a hitch but we would
love we were in love absolutely
absolutely you know uh PaRappa the
Rapper
I love that that game was the first
music game
that I actually purchased and repped
because you know at that point in time
you really didn't know and Sony was
Pioneers in this field because they were
doing things
especially with 3D especially with sound
because it was on CD yeah
um they they were doing things they were
Trend Setters to be honest with you
absolutely absolutely and that's the and
a lot of people get mad at me because
they say oh you hate Sony no I hate the
new ones because this only follows but
they don't lead and I love what they
used to be so yeah and you had that I'm
seeing folks in the chat Wipeout Ridge
rate like yes
so let me tell you why I'm bringing this
up first let's go because that demo disc
eventually failed
it started playing but it wouldn't play
every game it would just play something
yeah but here's the key so we would you
know and and I've heard a lot of people
make this game pass analogy you know
remember back in the day when you used
to go to the when you go to the rental
store or rent games yeah that's what
that's what we used to do not too short
not too short a distance like it was so
short that that even the kids who aren't
allowed to cross the street can go to
the game store yeah we knew them they
knew us we'd go rent some games right
now parallel to this time I think I was
what 15 16. that's parallel to this time
I was making music me and my boys were
doing things yes we were kids craziness
right I was DJing on the side you know I
was doing a bunch of different things DJ
okay I was doing a bunch of different
things right so at that time A buddy of
mine was like hey have you heard this
new technology thing you're into
technology there's this amazing
technology it's called mp2 yo yo he
ain't say mp2 I was like yo what is this
oh see all these huge crates you take
with you on all your gigs yeah it can
all be just right in this thing here
look at this blew my mind back of the
head right so started hunting started
you know and and you're younging into
the Netherlands at the time you could
you know we were doing we was hustling
and by hustling I don't mean the
American Hustle I'm talking about
you would do it what you had to do to
get there had to be done to get what was
necessary so yes I'm DJing I'm getting
money and I'm I'm doubling my income
every time I get a new gig so I'm buying
PC equipment at the time my uncle is
like doing real big he's showing me how
to do PC so I build a small little PC I
I put a CD burner in it because I need
mp2s
I was going to tell you like you know
you should you should have just come see
me when your your demo this failed I
could have resurfaced it
was that the um the PlayStation war with
the blue bottoms yeah yeah you had to
learn how to resurface
one day uh and you know I'm doing this
PC stuff and the demo disc fails we go
to the store we rent a bunch of games
here and there one day I rent Mortal
Kombat Trilogy
right and I'm like you know what
I know you can't do this but that's you
know statute of limitations that's your
limitations limitations up this is not
this I made a copy of this disc in
it doesn't play I'm like dude
[Music]
but you found a working disc the demo
disc would load up there you go so what
did I do a nice little swap
only thing that ever worked I played
Mortal Kombat Trilogy for
probably
all of the rest of 24 of 1990s
and and it turned into like it
eventually got me a bunch of a bunch of
people that would come to the house we
were doing tournaments
moms knew outside was not necessarily
the greatest place you should be all the
time so she'd be cool with me bringing
people over nice so it was you know you
know the boys the girls they'd be
hanging out in the house
this is why you've heard me say to you
like when y'all when y'all speak I'm
just like you guys we are Kindred
Spirits remember remember what it was
like and and that's why every time I see
y'all on the show
that is so crazy I can't interrupt you
it's just so crazy the reason why I love
these gaming history segments is because
and being kicks off and we talked about
it it's like
in your in at the time we're all in our
own separate worlds right
and we think what we're doing is so
unique because no one else and then when
you we meet all these people we bring
away the realm and you hear the stories
like yo and just even the international
scene I love when you mentioned
Netherlands and as we've had mods awful
we've had so many people from different
countries and you like yo the the
passion for gaming was the same in all
of these pockets all over the world
everyone was thirsty for the knowledge
and doing what they had to do to play
these games it is so fire to hear these
stories continue continue bro this is
fantastic no absolutely so so needless
to say I you know having found that out
you know made it like lifelong friends
and and one of my boys like I've known
him for my almost my entire life he is
now uh he's an ex developer but he's
worked for all your famous developers
say something he's probably worked there
I met him that's how we met we met
playing games we met MK tournaments you
know he's worked for your epics he's
worked for your EAS he's worked
everywhere and I still communicate with
him that's how we connected from way
back in the day right so so we did all
that and then eventually I think it was
early early 2000 you know my mother was
like hey it's time to get serious it's
time to do so I left the Netherlands and
uh at the time I'd worked worked things
out my dad and I was like all right you
can come come live back in the States so
in 2001 is when I moved back here and
I've been here ever since right so in
2001 I lived in New England when I first
moved to the states lived in New England
I'm like no I'm a living myself got a
little little spot my uncle trying to
start a little hustle dad hooked me up
he was a FedEx driver at the time
in New England oh yeah
and Christmas you you you're a
dark-skinned man in New England
um I'm a dark-skinned man in Florida oh
my God from the fire pan Into the Fire
because I was out in Boston and I found
out a lot of things very quickly
yes in New England
needless to say my first job after
working you know I worked FedEx and this
and that my first job
EB Games you made it yo how did you feel
when they gave you your name badge
bro I was so excited because at the time
it was the only place and at that time I
had just moved to the states I think I
hustled I'd hustled my way into like a
buddy giving me like an old Dreamcast
right and like the Dreamcast is like my
game of all you need to love that so I
had just moved to States I have a
Dreamcast I have you know your your Jet
Set radios you know I'm playing you know
I'm playing your Sega rallies this and
that right and I've been playing it for
a while and I'm liking it but this was
during a time when this was during a
time when Sega when dreams all I came
here is as soon as you said Sega rally
game over again
the most exciting game
is it EB Games just another game like
another game yeah it was Babbage and
then yeah EB was bought out by GameStop
and they all became GameStop but at the
time EB and GameStop were competitive
competitors yeah yeah at that time so
I'm working there and this this is the
first and I was there and what basically
what happened was this was the year this
was 2001 May or June like this was the
year that the Xbox the OG Xbox was
coming out right I am a Dreamcast guy I
have a Dreamcast the house love a
Dreamcast you know and then I'd walk by
the EB Games at Providence Place Mall in
Rhode Island I see I see this game where
you got you got there's a kiosk there's
like four people standing at the kiosk
yeah and there's like a whole bunch of
people behind them this in line waiting
and I'm like what the hell is going on
so I go and I get closer and it's like
there's a dude in a car and the others
are in the car as well
and it hadn't been released yet yes it
was you know it's coming soon coming
soon people saw it was in the kiosk I
was in I was so what brother absolutely
I hate to cut you because you you taking
me back to a Time cap so you're
absolutely right because at the time
Microsoft was really trying to get
awareness out and what they did was put
the kiosks in all the EBS the games that
all the and they would let you replace
with all the places yeah no no please it
was in all the places that we're going
to be carrying the Xbox Brands yes so
that was the deal that they had with all
the districts and not all Distributors
carried them right because people really
don't remember
[Laughter]
at that point in time we didn't know the
politics of the stuff we we were just
completely 100 game as we really was
going by what we can afford like yeah
those those kiosks was very key to
getting a cultural awareness
absolutely I walked in looking at that
thing going yo I gotta have this game I
walked out with a job and a mission to
get one yeah
we're not even game yes sir let me ask
you a question when you played the demo
because we all walk up to the kiosk and
we all put the fat Duke in our hand Paul
and hey hey hey I will I will accept no
Duke slander I can't have a Duke
shout out to Adam you got me big bad
heads slow down here six foot four and
that's still way too big of course
um
so so
what what part of the the demo for Halo
was the aha moment because everybody I I
know you was kidding I know you are I
think everybody has this one moment this
is one moment
with that game
what was your aha moment that you said
oh this is completely different
so what got me in the room was seeing a
bunch of people in line waiting to play
it right and then what really what the
aha moment for me was you know you play
it for a while it stops the kiosk
restarts and then a new bunch of people
get to try right so they restarted a new
bunch of people get to try and where the
game the demo starts is right when when
the pillar bottom is about to like crash
and you know Captain Keys who was a a
nice Caucasian
thank God you got the role brother
let me stop let me stop okay so and
they're crashing and you know you go
through the cinematics right at that end
you don't even get to play on the the
ship yeah right at the end and then you
land uh it crashes you know there's
nothing we could do uh Cortana says it
in your in your visor in your head yes
and you look up and you know and they're
coming to weeks we we suggest you escape
yes yes that was it you look up to the
sky you see that I was just like yo this
is
a Dreamcast I was hoping to see at the
time I'd play PC games so I know hey you
know people can really take it there
cinematically I've never seen that like
with this and then all of a sudden when
the cinematics end and it's a
multiplayer game so then the other three
people can like file into them and
they're going this is shooting that
person I was it's a wrap that was it
okay
it's good you know
I think I know yours okay I pulled up
the kiosk got the control on my hand you
know you look at everybody
you fell in your head I'm gonna play it
better than anybody that played it
before whatever and I'm going in and it
felt very intuitive right
I went into a dark
area
and
no it said hit the white button oh yeah
flashlight camera buttons the flashlight
on the gun
and I'm doing this and I'm looking and
you're projecting it and the light is
bouncing off of things and it's just
like ice that moment for me that's the
moment I turned around and gave them my
money
um
pre-order automatic we we stayed
um waiting for it but that was the
moment
I knew they had something yeah because
this is something I've never seen before
preached in a Home console game and I
want to sprout on that because that was
one for me the second was right after
you know all hell breaks loose pillow
autumn you know the the Covenant are on
you guys obviously you got your little
you know say the guys though you got
your leads and all that but I remember
most games at the time people gotta
understand
it was very basic you shoot they're
there I'm throwing a grenade and they're
moving out the way yeah and they're not
trying to get insane and I'm like wait a
minute what is this like you're supposed
to die I'm just I'm the star and they
was talking to you and you know they get
up and I'll say the demons here and I'm
like what is that like there was a level
of AI that Bungie was doing that we
never saw at that time in first person
Ai and physics and physics physics yeah
the thing is when you threw a grenade
down and and and it and it everything
around it blew up in the in the proper
manner right yeah
oh my God I had only again I don't even
know this was 2001 I'm trying to
remember hey because again the only
other aha moment I had at that point I
think and I might be wrong about the
timing was the gravity gun in Half-Life
2. never seen physics before before that
so man that was special also my chaos my
kiosk at the time and I found this later
I found out this later because I ended
up working there getting to know the
people that were there they turned the
difficulty up to heroic
oh get you out of there quick yeah
and I was murking you like it was just
like
I remember the first thing I played on
Halo was multiplayer on blood gold oh
God oh my goodness I didn't touch the
story till after oh so you probably at
first
um Public Service Announcement
Public Service Announcement we have over
700 people here we all have 200 likes
alike you know quesante is giving you
his childhood he's giving you his
history and we're dropping Jim sprinkled
in between please [ __ ] us out hit the
like button
no doubt continue adding I'm sorry
you're saying also that soldiers playing
the uh the multiplayer first and then
that's yeah
first thing I did was the multiplayer
because like I said um I came from
I got the the original Xbox for fable
and I got the 360 for fable 2. like Halo
was an afterthought oh Halo yeah it's
like I remember like I bought a 360 when
Fable came out you know what's funny I
never knew that face that's because I've
never had a history
that the host didn't do his homework
is that what we were playing that needs
to happen
you know attic is a step child he
doesn't you know he doesn't get that
I don't do them like that
yo the funny thing is that but
there was worry about Halo right because
we didn't know yeah we didn't know what
it was going to be we saw the kiosk
right but again real time even back then
even back then you know we were like
hold up this you know this ain't the
full game we don't know what this is
right so not until the reviews came out
up until the reviews came out I was most
excited for deadly live three because I
was like oh my God I can't believe
they're doing this on this machine this
PlayStation
the next level to have that level of
Graphics just by the game at home no it
wasn't until the reviews came out and I
remember I remember shout out to Rod
McCaffrey official Xbox a magazine
hold up what's going on here yeah and
then there was just eights and nines and
tens yeah it was like tens
you know that's the first time and I'm
gonna keep raising my hand because it's
just a habit
um okay so I have to got to cook it
right there
that's the first time I heard the the
name game killer app yes killer app
first time because yes they stay
Associated Halo with the uh Xbox console
and they said Xbox has their first
killer app and I'm like what the hell is
that absolutely yeah
I I do feel like without Halo and gears
we you would have an Xbox without gears
but I don't think you would have it
without him it wouldn't have as without
Halo and I think Halo brought it to the
point where it was actually took
seriously during the Xbox one yeah but I
think the 360 gears is what turned it
means yeah I agree 100 100
you know and it was between it was
between gears and Halo 3 because I feel
like Halo 3 did a lot for the Xbox brand
and you know I love playing you know we
we play Shout out to the community
stream we played it for a couple hours
yesterday but like even though how fun
that was
okay I will never forget like the snow
map on Halo 3 going to the little bunker
is it yeah you know fight for the
shotgun just tossing grenades in there
because like I personally feel like
grenades is a shell of what it used to
be like grenades used to actually be
like pretty much just as good as a heavy
weapon as long as you use them correctly
but now it's just it feels like it's
just oh you shot a good time throw some
grenades yeah it's Gotta like the willow
down but we got to get back over okay
side these guys jump into a whole bag of
a Halo appreciation but not continue
eBay yeah no let's continue so yeah I
got a job uh working at EB uh stop
working FedEx uh the first Christmas
when Halo at on the games and everything
you know you had your NFL fever when
they first I was there I was at that EB
when they first started selling the
console and they had this deal okay guys
let's go for every Xbox console you sell
you'll get it x amount of percentage for
yourself it was my first Christmas day
let me tell you my check was bigger than
anybody
holy crap you'd have no idea
yes so no after that uh and then I made
the first mistake that I usually made
that I did not uh uh make again I ended
up putting packaging together because at
the time I was like I have to have it I
hadn't gotten my first check yet but I
gotta have it let's go put together my
Dreamcast okay all the games and traded
them in to get the OG Xbox
how much have a Star Credit would you
give him I'm not even gonna go there I
still keep myself
because it was the black Dreamcast it
was the Japanese
I have since I've only gotten almost all
the consoles that that are back now I
have my OG that one I still cannot get
it and shout out to Mr Boomstick I know
he's got one yes and every time he talks
about it I'm just like oh yo they
actually get us as kids back yeah my dad
my dad had a a bunch of consoles and
stuff uh it's at my grandparents I
actually think think they he had a black
segment but he could be it could also be
the Sega Sports one right yeah he's
talking about the Japanese one Japanese
yeah but there was an American Sega
Sports one yeah I think that also came
packed in with a game a couple games
yeah yeah yeah probably 2K1 2K1 today
yeah shout out to ham solo he said
that's the way we used to live we
couldn't afford it so you had to trade
in the old one to the new one that's
just what's the reality let me shout out
to it I was broke as a joke we had we
had to try to get it that was the only
way so you looked at your old thing he's
like man yeah so you had to do it right
yeah officially look over and say who's
not producing who's that producer
let's say the PlayStation 3 is coming
out in in six months right right now
this moment right now this PlayStation 2
ain't gonna be valued no higher you've
got just to go buddy
continue I remember around like the
original Xbox there was like a good year
and a half I didn't have any console
yeah that's when I got the the Fable the
Fable uh one ah no Doug that was one of
my favorite games you know what the the
most depressing thing was like the
original because I got the game it was
the green Xbox
see through one yeah
I got Fable with it and it would always
get to like the screen where the
Assassin's opening and it makes the logo
history and every time it would freeze
there I I had to go buy another copy of
fable because it was broke like it was
too scratched up it was like it
literally sometimes it would go through
so I'm literally launching this sucker
like eight times to try to get past that
title screen one time salute bro yo I
didn't realize that how much fate was
important to you everybody has their
their attachment to the system right
what got them continue games out of this
fight no so so basically the the X the
OG X Box was like it was the beginning
of my gaming life it really was because
that was the first console that I
actually you know my boy hooked me up
with it with the Dreamcast but that was
the first console I was like okay I
traded some in and I paid a little extra
and I got that I got it with the with
the extra controller and a bunch of
games and it kind of put me on a path
that really like I guess I would say
that console is kind of responsible for
a lot of the things that happened to me
up until up until now so so uh and and
of course still this was 2001. so the
statute of limitation on this yeah let's
continue
let's just say that console eventually
uh obviously it was a Windows 2000 yeah
you know so I will tell you and you know
broad strokes but yes
there's a rumor that somebody is a box
box no no it doesn't follow me the room
is somebody took an Xbox that was
put through the ringer yes yes and
handed it to either Bill Gates or
somebody put it on somebody's desk and
said do you see what they're doing with
our machines
and in the tiniest teeniest tiniest way
eventually that turned into Netflix that
turns the the media streaming the media
center
most teeny tiniest way possible I was I
I helped bring that to this yeah that's
why it's so important you know you know
what it is though right because itself
Bill Bill Gates's original plan for the
Xbox all right you go back to go back to
the Xbox documentary and shame is black
and what they were talking about they
promised the PC in the living room right
they promised all of that functionality
when it wasn't that he was so livid that
they had to resell him on the prospect
of what Xbox would be and at the very
least the internet stuff and getting
everybody online and connected that's
what resold him but when you showed him
something like that somebody was hacking
it and turning it more into that turning
it more into that PC in the living room
that's what opened his eyes and was like
wait a minute yeah so that was really
it's funny because you look at your
product you're like damn they hacked the
hell out of this thing literally the the
community showed him the k
ick the cave where this could go go
everybody who's who's enjoying all the
things you enjoy about your your
one-dimensional device that used to be
just be your game player preach it thank
you thank your local tinkerer
I'll take I'll take that I like that
yeah
better than criminal
what's funny is like Microsoft was
famous for taking respect and I think
they're the first people to integrate
Netflix onto their platforms
they brought Netflix and kicking and
screaming they were the first people to
reach out to they killed Blockbuster
they were the first people to integrate
Minecraft I remember they came out
initially and got that going they're
doing the Discord thing now
for real like when it comes to social
aspects they've always been on top of
that yeah it's a case of these credit
you know I remember just being blown
away I remember I was such a again being
a very Kinder Spirit here because I'm
such a music guy that I would literally
burn all my favorite albums remember
that hard drive and I that was the the
debuted Genesis of custom soundtracks
and being just being mind blown and say
you know what I don't have to listen to
The King's Music
Gotham Racing you're like screw that
exactly you know what that did us doing
that Xbox having the ability to do that
forced EA yes and everybody else to go
to these rappers and to sign them up to
do uh soundtracks for live remember live
yeah yeah Nas was I'm like yeah what
that's nice
I wish that because I know there's like
something with Microsoft and
and Google with YouTube like I wish that
well you could do a Spotify as long as
you have premium you can do YouTube
because like they didn't they brought
some of that aspect from the 360 to the
Xbox one but they didn't bring all of it
like they left a lot of it there and it
was just like I remember playing those
old games and you could choose what you
play it was always like a perfect
balance too with the game and the actual
music and uh you know I Spotify is okay
but it's just like man just let me play
YouTube videos in the background on Xbox
man yeah it was it was a big deal it
like like you said it was a tigger's
dream the customization the hard drive
you know ethernet in the Box all of that
Xbox Live I understand why it's
especially I think I already know the
answer to when we get to consoles so you
know where you gonna go that's what
started with me that's what started you
know and then of course you know
eventually I was working at EB so I I
played all the consoles I started PS2 I
never bought a PS2 really
why because at the time I was working at
EB obviously I was working a lot at EB
it was all I wanted to do I want to be
around video games all thank you
we had a stock room
full of broken ps2s like you know how
you have that little yellow dot
eventually it had two discs but remember
at the time and I'm sure solve you know
what I'm talking about a choice between
the OG lens and the DVD lens yes
eventually one of the motor would break
and whichever one was stuck at the top
is the one that you'd have forever yeah
we have people coming to the house
coming to the store going oh yeah it
doesn't play any of my blue discs
anymore oh it doesn't play any of my
white my black disc anymore had broken
to whichever way
so we had like hundreds of broken ps2s
back there so I was just like nope and
they just swapped that under the rug oh
it's amazing to me but the red ring of
death is the thing right bro 100 King I
am to this day it stuns me as much as
many broken ps2s as I had in the back of
my store room I am stunned that we did
not hear as much red ring kind of energy
because it was Major it was a lot see
the thing this is the difference the
bomber that's the difference
we can sweep this stuff away and act
like it doesn't happen and we can just
look the other way
I gotta step here flag on the field okay
I love you but we're not gonna not give
before there was a Phil Dominus
there was a Peter more sir
our brand will forever be this one put
his neck on the line at that time Steve
Ballmer was that dude to get you out of
here yeah get you out of here so we got
to give respect on my man name your man
definitely okay
that's what he was gonna say God yeah
but he he did he never let me finish I'm
sorry I'm sorry I got to post you I
thought Peter was gonna get it get his
new flowers
in the comment section I interrupted I
apologize and and the fact that they had
to do that to save face Sony was an
already already established entity in
the Juggernaut in the space so it's very
common place to turn your face the other
way when something's going wrong like
whatever it's not nothing it's only a
small percentage
and again I mean you know to be fair at
that time this was like you know early
2000s yeah I didn't have the full
metrics of it it's just my small perch
and my small store in that small
location I had a lot of them and I was
just like very surprised but because of
that it kind of I played it at the store
I enjoyed it but I never actually bought
it because I'd seen so many of those so
so I think it was uh my my girlfriend at
the time bought me a PS3 the fat the
fact you got the George Foreman grill
yeah George Foreman Grill which is live
and kicking today wow you got the
original right oh
yes
so you had a PlayStation
by default yeah I ran Linux on the thing
because yeah
oh wait hold on you ain't take the
lawsuit bunny I'll take the lawsuit
everybody got the 21 bucks
hey they said Linux is supposed to be on
it that the new iteration stop having
lyrics
I love my PS3 I still had a PS3 but a
bunch of games you know Die Hard PS3
dude I really enjoyed the PS3 uh PS4 of
course ever since that time I've been
you know every every time every concert
and I mean like and of course as I said
you know where where I originally came
from so now when I have the chance to it
it becomes a bit of problem that my my
wife tends to you know you have to
regulate
she's The Regulators in the house now
I have all the almost all the main
consoles which including Dreamcast I'm
trying to get that back and then I want
to get the Obscure stuff you know yeah
yeah like the um
no doubts
the only thing I'll say though is you
know now here I am with with all of it
since that time of me wanting to you
know play and do all that so every OG
console I have has been on the mission
and and I'll leave it at that and I
think some people will understand every
console I've had up until now has been
on the mission that has not been been
fulfilled until the steam deck
awesome all in one put everything
that is why it is the greatest thing
I've ever had in my in my possession it
is all of them okay no salute salute to
you man tremendous Gamers but you know
we can talk to you on this gaming Man
Forever brother like you got your
stories brother really quickly I do want
to ask you now obviously how I came
across you you being a podcast
connoisseur right and I'm like KSI he's
in this [ __ ] okay he's over here he's
over there he's everywhere this kid you
know so it's like you know the
transition now because obviously you're
doing your thing a tech background but
like what made you jump into the space
now say hey I want to do this and be a
consequence sure sure so this was let's
see this was so as as everybody knows
you know you whether you're you're a
part of the community like either in the
chat or you're on these things on these
uh podcasts you know we all have these
conversations we all have these debates
you know which console and what you like
and I played PC as well I just love
games so I play whatever whatever I can
get my hands on but during the OG Xbox
Xbox One slash PS4 gen and you know they
had the trouncing that we all remember
right I love my PS4 you know I was just
chilling but I also had an OG I had an
Xbox one I loved the idea of the connect
but not the execution I was one of the
guys who was taking the connect plug it
into the PC yeah
she was doing really interesting things
and at some point the conversation
started you know there was there was
technical conversations being had and
and like like I said I've always been on
a tech trajectory at the time I've been
working in Tech you know working in
pharmaceutical working in technology uh
I I've built games
[Music]
I will never release a game okay
okay I always did you know uh uh shout
out to the Xbox they you know they they
turned the OG Xbox One into a Dev cake
tickering and you know all that stuff
you know so there's been talking about
devops now we you know I do some of that
for for work so so you know yeah so so
what actually really really got me into
the conversation like you asking
specifically what got me into wanting to
content create is when I kind of delved
deep a little bit into what Xbox had
done from 360 to Xbox One yes and the
the the operating system changes and
moving to the cloud and like because I
for my work I do a lot of virtualization
I do a lot of architectural
infrastructure things like that so I
deal with virtual machines and
hypervisors
Microsoft like is using hyper-v to do
all of this moving and shake it and I'm
just like what the actual word I can't
use yes
like man and you start digging into it
and you see what they're doing and it's
just so technology driven and so
forward-looking and man it is my I'm
waiting for the book I want to read it
yeah I want to read who decided that
we're going to put like three four
operating systems in a game console yeah
whatever you want it it's just gonna pop
up and it's going to be its own
operating system in account like it's
just my mind so when people started
talking about oh well the Xbox can't do
this or Playstation can't do that or
whatever I was like come on guys you
don't know how amazing this stuff
actually is yeah the implementation and
what you see it's just oh yeah it just
pops up and you're playing right but
when that's when that that like slide
side thing when uh
the Snapchat that's a whole different
options
bro it was very ambitious absolutely
right so that's what really got me into
wanting to you know get in there and
start and I heard a few you know people
were having some conversations were
being had where you know maybe some
falsehoods were being graduated
I'm an avid fan you know
shout out to Mr Boone his podcast a lot
and a few other folks and I was just
like man I wish I could I want to talk
and say Hey you know
maybe maybe what you're seeing as
disappointed as you may be you know if
you knew some of the logistics that got
you there or why it is that it does what
it does why it is that from 360 you had
all these features and then Xbox one you
got nothing you know they literally
rebuilt the they they reinvented the
wheel right which let's give them the
right to smoke they deserve yeah you
remember through the wheel but you
should have added all those features
people liked before yeah yeah I agree
you know but I wanted to be part of that
conversation and and an opportunity
presented itself I sent uh I sent boom a
message he was like oh bro of course and
we started chat oh the legendary you
invited me on so so in the beginning
when y'all said hey shout out to Mr
Boomstick he's put so many people on I
can attest if it wasn't for Mr Boomstick
I would not be here today shout out to
you Mr Boomstick happy birthday happy
birthday yo put the questions yesterday
I love that man because at the end of
the day y'all can say whatever I want
about my brother he gave so many people
opportunities so many people and not
only to give people opportunity he also
shines spot likes on people and the men
who are doing their thing we were very
blessed to be on on the show at one time
got us over the hump when we were trying
to get to a thousand Subs you know what
I'm saying yeah tremendous Community
manager shout out to business boom it is
boom sticks birthday I want everybody to
tweet at Mr Boomstick happy born day put
the crest up for us at the end of the
day you may not agree with everything as
far as baby but as a person don't ever
come for my bro like he's that guy he's
a good dude salute to Mr happy birthday
bro I got on the show you know after one
conversation he he said I sounded like
Mark monarden I guess I'll take that as
a compliment
you know because he's co-writing that
Black Panther game
he offered me a spot on the panel you
know and of course me and me and shout
out to the homie Mr ever born oh which
Toby did he Super Chat I gotta break
protocol to say remember that you're
gonna owe him knees for some bet with
Sonic and and is this the God of War
Sonic bet are you are you looking Shady
that Sonic by outsell God of War let's
take a quick decide real quick let me
fill you all in on the creek yes yes
let's go so so I'm talking to ever born
ever born Judas
let's go he is he is Sonic man number
one yes
our show does not end Sonic or Sega
reference oh yeah you know what's going
on yeah that's just
what I mean I'm like why is it the
Microsoft is not you know talking to son
to to Sega
let's get let's get let's get Frontiers
let's get Frontiers in game pass because
let's be honest here right that day is a
stacked day with some Heavy Hitters
right you want as much promotion and as
much signal boosting as you can get and
right now I don't see Sega doing that
right and he's like he's like oh I know
this game is going to be amazing it's
gonna be eight plus if not more high but
but ideally if it reaches critical
status uh we're critics but still does
not make the money that it needs to be
made I will leave them in a position to
be ready for for you know I'm like so
you are waiting you you want this thing
to fail so the the competitor so that
they're on their knees waiting for
somebody acquired you know his Grand
Vision I already know because of that I
call this man ever born Jude how could
you love Sonic so much I want to throw
that little Sonic to the Wolves right
because
he just understands that if they do
succeed yeah the chances of them turn
into them saying yeah we could be a
quiet it's definitely zero yeah it goes
against his daughter
so I called booty because I'm like did
you hear this craziness this wild
Madness that
ever born is spouting he goes oh I'll
tell you this not only will Sonic beat
without without uh without any backing
or any support from Microsoft not only
will Sonic Beat Ragnarok it'll be two to
one I'm like
you can't you can't go to Boom to bring
you back down to earth
he shoots for the stars
now both of them are like oh yeah oh
those two together boom boom is like two
to one ever born is like at least it'll
be it'll Beat it I'm just like
and and their reason is sound right you
know Ragnarok is on two platforms maybe
eventually get to the third which would
be it should be PC right Sonic is
everywhere Sonic is having a moment
Sonic has great game uh great TV show
yeah the static hype and a great movie
but
while they all the the wind is at
Sonic's back and it's all for them to
gain because it's everywhere it will
only succeed if Sonic is good
that is good point a monster like that's
a variable it's a variable yeah that's
America that's a variable because we've
seen Sonic Colors
it keeps happening you know what I'm
saying
and I want them to win because I think
you know I'm old school I'm from the
time when Sonic was great and I want
Sonic to continue to be great but that
if bro that if stands in my way facts
I'm waiting for I'm I'm gladly ready to
relinquish the knees if I lose but y'all
are just circumventing that if they
deliver to to Casual with the if okay
now
I love a bad salute to ever boy salute
the boom on that man again soy so you
know so you rise there and then
obviously from where you are now the KSI
YouTube channel gaming Circle podcast
hooking up with the very opinionated yet
super knowledgeable entrepreneur and
mostly slanderous ever boy Saga so like
how did that connection just say what
was the Genesis yeah it was you know
connecting with boom boom had already
connected with with uh with Eva born and
he and I just connecting the DMS we
started chatting you know it's movies
it's TV it's games it's just the
industry it's technology in general he's
a technologist I'm a technologist you
know we we we we go back and forth and
we were having a lot of great podcasts
on the phone right it just kind of
happens that way hey how you doing bro
we start chatting and before long we're
like two three hours in we're like we
could have recorded facts
we initially we're like maybe we should
do some spaces and then quickly spaces
turned out to be maybe not the best uh
use of our time so we were like you know
okay so let's start let's start you know
and and dip our toe into the podcast
game and we're already panelists on Boom
show so we know how it's done he's
giving us a privilege you know he's
helping us get in in the game initially
we started doing on the Reel with with
everyone here he had that right I love
that music
I know I know the kind of tastes I'm
like that's my joke and shout out to on
the real it might it might come back oh
okay no doubt no doubt you know but time
is you know time is of the essence
there's so much to be done and not
enough time to do it with so we We
Shrunk the show to one and now we're you
know every Saturday you know he and I
get on and we're trying to the timing is
a little funky you know it's the only
time he and I can get the chance to do
so but unfortunately that makes it
difficult to invite a bunch of people
because Saturday morning sisters
no we've been we've been having a good
time and people people seem to be
enjoying it it's growing exponentially
so we're really happy with not
absolutely got to put that in the chat
man catch that game of circle podcast on
the K Asante YouTube channel go over
there and subscribe tremendous I got a
chance like I said I'll get a chance to
listen to podcasts like I used to but
what I do do listen to you you guys
really want a good show it's fun it's
entertaining and it's very knowledgeable
it's very Tech based I love you know a
little bit of Pop Culture a little bit
of the bullies you get a little bit of
everything and it's really good man so
keep up with your journey there you know
what I'm saying yeah we are literally
walking on the shoulders of giants that
is the ILP we appreciate you guys so
much you have no idea oh thank you
brother it meant a lot to hear that you
um you know how you guys found us and
listen to us and all that other good
stuff so we got to ask the question that
you know we're here for I mean as a as a
veteran listener okay so that you know
what time it is right now pull up your
spreadsheets you know what I'm saying or
whatever you need but I need more
ksati's top five video games or
franchises of all time
top five and franchises right franchises
can be loose they could be friends yeah
you can do franchises you can absolutely
okay top five number five Tetris
[Music]
any kind of Tetris because it's just
definitively one of the best games ever
made and that dude who did not copyright
it in the 80s when he made it still
should be kicking yourself today and he
should be as rich as not a notch right
now yeah he should be doing that Alexi
Alexi project yes yes Tetris uh let's
see franchise is Mario anything Mario
2D 3D doesn't matter like I I'm I'm a
Mario guy you know to me that's that's
one of the OG stuff you know uh I play
Mario maker with my kids all the time my
kids my daughter's like really into I
want to build you a video game I'm like
oh yeah
he's starting up early let's go
indoctrination indoctrination let's go
you know so yeah where am I so I have
two you guys have Mario yeah all right
uh three
Mass Effect
no no you're gonna stay away
you stayed away okay okay okay
franchise I bet you I can advance search
his name on Twitter yeah and then find
out what he said
and what I will say is like and I I I
kept up with all all the the drama when
you guys were going through it thank God
I am with the art I am absolutely with
you addict that if you are new to the
franchise oh three is the best oh he's
if you are new to the franchise
because you've gone through all the
drama and it's basically the culmination
of all of the technical uh skills but if
you started with it
[Music]
so number two number two two and one two
and one let's go oh goodness gracious
let's see two and one number two man
that is difficult God of War
[Music]
OG or the new thing here we go here we
go you know you know and I know you're
gonna come for me King no I appreciate I
appreciate the OG and I also appreciate
the new because the OG was just awesome
it established the character it really
defined who you were playing and what
you want you were there for right the
radical and all of that and it just so
happened that when God award 2018 hit I
was uh we were having my first child
right so that whole boy that whole
situation really hit me different so
because of that I can appreciate them
both for a different reason you know
what I'm saying but if that hadn't been
in me I see where you're coming from
where they they strayed so far from the
OG character that some might not
necessarily be with that right and just
look like Gears of War sure sure it's
the relationships that kept me there
right it's the whole the whole because I
have I have a tumultuous relationship
with my dad I saw this whole thing
that's all of this you know but the
story hooked you because of God not the
actual game just the story
wow I love throwing the ax the moment to
Moment by Golden
axis
and it is still as good as it was I love
God Awards no doubt yeah shout out to
Nexus
that's my heart
from the home team in the Netherlands
that's right Miles Morales coming to see
you soon
and of course the number one franchise
which nobody would would be surprised by
just sheer hours of play time and it
could be technical or it could just be
because I've always just loved the story
so much I have played it for about five
years almost straight I've played all of
the campaigns through oh countless times
okay Halo yeah I don't know I thought he
was gonna say Destiny well you know
Destiny began is a close second oh
because like remember Microsoft did that
museum thing yes yes I've been playing
The Insider with with Halo because Halo
Master Chief Collection came out you
know me I'm a technologist the idea that
they were stitching net code from so
many different code bases to get I'm
like this is impossible it will never
work you guys are crazy and then of
course it didn't work at start but I was
part of that Insider program so I've
been playing that campaign for like
years but if you look at my play time in
the Halo thing Destiny one is it a close
second yeah
you have like five six days
regardless how bad the Master Chief
Collection staying the the Halo
franchise like I don't think people
realize that Master Chief Collection
it's it's relatively working great now
oh yeah it's great they're they're
probably being never be another game
that does something like that yeah yeah
it was the Master Chief Collection it
was The Orange Box
let's go let's go it is the Museum of
Halo we all deserve so yes Halo 100 no
doubt it's my number one franchise of
all time tremendous five and of course
the final question that we ask and I
think we all know the answer to this one
I still gotta ask it favorite console of
all time and why
no
um obviously it's the OG Xbox uh you
know I'm not I don't tend to be Warrior
of consoles and whatnot I love my my
consoles all all facets but as you guys
have heard that original Xbox and I
still have that original Xbox in my
office the OG one I I recently upgraded
the hard drive with a terabyte drive I'm
keeping that thing alive I'm gonna hand
that to my children one day you know
that thing to me is you know it it
changed my even my career it really
changed my the way I technically thought
of things so yeah it has to be OG Xbox
no doubt no doubt salute to the OG ksr
TV tremendous gaming history love these
stories salute to of course the gaming
Circle pockets and the King Assad
YouTube channel y'all put the channel up
in the chat make sure y'all go sub to
the brother let's get them over that
let's get the move a thousand subscribe
you know what I'm saying listen they got
a really good show going on man please
check it out go subscribe put them up in
there in the chat now so I'm gonna get a
super chats ready or you want me to get
the poll first
maybe one or two that came in at the end
doubt No Doubt last week Paul was
supposed to end the people spoken with
the recent departures at 343 as reported
by lordsgaming.net how confident are you
that the Halo franchise can turn itself
around moving forward the winner of the
three-way ILP poll at 64 of the vote was
343's recent changes has renewed faith
for the long-term commitment to Halo
coming in at second place with 25
percent of the vote was after Master
Chief Collection at Halo infinite's lack
of content not optimistic with 343 as a
franchise with the franchise group and
then and that last place that close but
nine percent of the vote was the messy
Lords I don't care I'm not trying to hit
anything until that Halo battle royale
drops Lloyd King the people have spoken
they say they failed it overall is a
renewed faith in in the the direction
that it changes what's your thoughts oh
that's the remains to be seen
um you you heard everybody on this panel
say
um the Halo Master Chief Collection uh
was something that shouldn't have been
done I don't know how they pulled it off
and they actually stood with it and
until it's completion so
um I don't know what other head is going
to show up and do that uh but uh if
y'all keep pointing off the fingers at
certain people when that person is no
longer there
I want y'all to look over at those those
situations and I want y'all to start
pointing fingers down and start saying
exactly what's really going on there
because you know I heard a whole lot of
rhetoric like you know trying to you
know put it on one person you got hope
right I date the same people to me
because if I hear it from a lot of
people uh she probably wasn't even in
the building for the past six seven
months so what happened then but I'm
just saying I will see I reserve
judgment until actually when it happens
because I'm gonna tell you the next
thing you ship
hey you know what
I still gotta ask you Spartan
you want some more after the
customization yeah you know because
because Sovereign said
they looked over at the landscape and
they looked at what was out there right
pubg ship broken
if you go to Pub G right now
Pub G has Seasons they have content and
it's revolving and this is stuff that
you have to do it has been a year buddy
you this is what the second season in a
year oh yeah for sure what the hell is
going on so again I'm gonna tell you
right now we need and the way I was
doing it
that was a No-No so why wouldn't the
individual is not there things ain't
changed when um Sean Laden was gone what
did Jim do drop the prices stuff
happened right so again A lot of times
you guys say it's one thing it may be
something completely different so I'm
not really optimistic at all oh oh you
bought it at 25
okay
when it comes to games being broken in
general because he's talking about the
Master Chief Collection all you got to
do is fix it like people can sit there
and say whatever they want you know this
company that that company did this you
know you know what's funny is cyberpunk
is having a surge on Steam right now so
it's like I said all you got to do is
fix it and the world will forgive you
said that live service is one of those
things if you do right yeah and you you
you can come back
on Netflix and then have the Zack guys
start all over again I I think that has
something to do with it but I think word
of mouth has more to do with it because
I was seen surging long before that show
launched it's like look like it's CD
projekt Red can recover from that and so
can the Master Chief collection and
Battlefield 4 and all these other
franchises like people be acting like
Master Chief like Halo infinite is in
the worst state that Halo's ever been on
I wouldn't want to keep that Master
Chief Collection was in the worst thing
I think the hard conversation to have
with Halo is
it do you continue this this
free-to-play service game thing or do
you move on from that at some point the
next Halo is just a core Halo
that's it the problem with Halo is
they're going to have to like the the
reason something like fortnite stuff
like Apex Legend works is because one
Apex Legends has a little bit more it
was built on a free to play when I see
Halo infinite it doesn't seem like it
was it was going to be a free to play
from day one I felt like that was
something that was probably put in there
uh you know when they saw the rise of
fortnite they saw the rise of Apex
Legends war zone they realized they
couldn't put Halo in there and compete
unless it was a free to play that's fine
but it's just like you have to build it
around a free to play model and it just
felt like this wasn't it's like look
like go wild like people sit there oh
they don't want emotes well that guess
what that's what's in games like these
days like you're gonna have to you know
whatever these crazy dances are you know
Massachusetts
don't sit there and they say I don't
want craters doing the Dougie well guess
what fortnite did it and you know Pro
most likely the next God of War gonna
sell better because it was in fortnite
so it's just like look you guys got to
get your your your Nostalgia out of the
fact because guess what these younger
Generations they don't care about your
Nostalgia because they don't have
that's why I always laughed when people
were making fun of Dr disrespect saying
that Halo infinite needed a a a battle
royale and people clown them for it's
like look like regardless how you like
there's reasons Battle Royale is lasted
as long as it is it's not just because
of the Gamo it's because you feel like
you're doing something new every time
you land one it is extremely streamable
because of the way it's structured
there's more reasons that that that
structure has lasted as long as it has
and that's why I felt like
Halo infinite should have it should have
launched with a battle royale and it
should have the option to go and play
Arena because you get you get people in
there with the Battle Royale and then
you get them in the arena and you start
cross promoting them like they do
fortnite like they do Destiny the
problem is they wanted to be destined
without Destiny was what I'm looking for
infrastructure uh Bungie has people can
sit there and say well they've learned
from Bungie look you're not in the board
rooms you don't understand what's going
on behind closed doors you can see their
mess-ups publicly but you're not in the
back to figuring out what they did to
fix this what they did to fix that yeah
you're not seeing the 80 different ways
that they were going to take destiny
that they didn't do and you're not
seeing all the back end you're just
seeing the front end
yeah so we got that out today as far as
the another Halo discussion
is crazy
he's just he just the shot Authority
[ __ ] he just gave uh the chat 2200 Halo
credits and he said don't be watched
yeah don't be walking around and that's
another thing like when you look at what
I look at fortnite and I'm looking
through these tears I'm like yo it don't
even I don't have to do much I'm gonna
get something nice yeah when I look at
Halo infinite I'm like I'm gonna give up
your firstborn
okay when I'm looking at the end of like
the seasons like there isn't a lot there
I want it's just like there's nothing
there I want yeah
what turned me off completely was after
I brought the season pass I still had to
buy stuff
um and I was like but I want this okay
well you have to do this minuscule stuff
that's over here that really has nothing
to do with nothing but you can only do
it on Tuesday at seven o'clock
what like I just didn't like the the way
it was structured and I'm pretty sure
that they're working on that stuff but
for people to say that
um if I have confidence in it I really
don't because it's been so long that
certain stuff that I think could be
fixed but they're not easy fixes I'm not
a Dev yeah right so one thing that might
get fixed it might break everything else
the fact that they were working on a new
map instead of fixing custom games like
that is big that's not small that's the
that's the foundation of hey the first
thing
was Maps
it's just like no at this point after
playing custom games the past couple
with the with the realm yeah fix that
yeah
if I can't even no but here's the thing
if you can't even get on and say y'all
want to spawn with BR and Cyprus and
they give you an AR and a sniper yeah
core Foundation what's the point of
Forge when you can't even play it in
custom games
fundamentally the the problem and you're
absolutely right someone can also say
that right just like you're saying how
the heck can they have this without the
fundamentals resolve someone can say
exactly the same thing with all the
desync issues how great your maps are
are and how great your your your your
menus are if you're in game and
someone's spawning out of nowhere just
killing you right because your network
connections are completely ridiculous it
does that too depends before because I
know I'll be going at them a lot but
yeah to their point these last all these
what is it the uh the drop pods all the
informational bits yeah have all been
about the focus has has been the core
gameplay fix first and then the content
map and how they expect it to come so
act like I'm part of the community and
I'll be knowing what's going on
get your balls over there
us playing you know I I always just I
always knew that the that Halo infinite
was in a bad part but us playing custom
games and the amount of issues that we
was running into just plain basic you
know we we did a game of Capture the
Flag beat him Capture the Flag the flag
was disappearing not re-sinking not
coming back and then it turned it into a
a Slayer that no one won because no one
did anything with the flags you can't
get the objectives though and then we
was having scenarios where King was on
my screen but I wasn't on his but we was
all in the party and it's just like
that's why people sitting there we want
new car now I want the existing content
to work like yeah yeah if the
fundamentals aren't aren't correct right
now I'm out of here 345 so let's get to
topics indeed
oh all right the uh Cog is not back yet
yeah I mean no we got to do the um the
Super Chat let's do super chats right
now yeah so give me one second anything
else pop in here yeah I got them all
all right let's go with a lot of them
too here's a couple uh flame member for
one year five dollars shout out to log
man howdy does it tell you that they've
been a member for a certain amount of
time now yeah Ben said it yeah uh five
dollar Cooper chat how many buckaroons
just dropping by to give a wholehearted
recommendation for cyberpunk Edge
Runners and Anime so good I'm even
thinking of playing the game I'm
actually I'm gonna play the game again
and I'm gonna watch the anime because
people have told me that the streets
have cooled down
we could do don't tell me time after you
extend the boy weekly podcast 30 minutes
well today I had to leave at 3 45 so
time
there we have Angus McDuff remember for
eight months
[Laughter]
what Satya said was the difference
between a CEO and a CFO I got a former
Arab Vibes this will be fun yeah the
first time nashata has engaged in this
discourse is uh yeah it's a little
different yeah I can't wait to my side
then we got no more Oscar five dollars
no more no more that's it
I enjoy hearing the guest history on
video game systems and where they
started in their favorite games man
y'all some undercover nerds like it's
not ain't no undercover about it that's
right there yeah I was straight outside
but if you said something to me I'd had
to rough you up
a lot of shared history there my mom's
too the work of the devil
shout out to to all the non-believers we
out here right all right
that we got the homie God's Hitman in
the Philippines
so how many do we have left we got a few
we got a group maybe like seven eight
more let's just read that after King
leaves because we only have him for 35
minutes I'm gonna fly through it yeah
then we got God's Hitman let's let's not
comment on all of them let's do that hey
guys okay I traded in my PS3 got 13 for
it wow wow
it sounded like game stock got ripped
off yeah yeah
what up Lords don't forget to ask Kay
about the knees he's gonna have to send
me and boom this holiday but doubting
Sonic also happy born day the book no
doubt thank you sir then we got the
homie big cloud gaming in the building
yeah salute to the fam like that in the
building hit that like button thank you
brother a little bit cloud what's going
on brother and we got Mandingo
mcstickets remember for two months five
dollars Super Chat not two years sorry
not two years five awesome chat when I
look down at the small windows on the
part of the on the podcast of the panel
I can see a pasty white dot whoa
happy Sunday Lord great show what up
Anna he messing with Adam stop being
messy stop that continue
oh my goodness then we got on a Taco
remember for one year care what that
dude got to say two dollars
Sonic was never great just good at its
people
smoking rocks yeah
I don't know you take the exclusivity
away I don't know you might be on
something continue
remember for two years fifty dollar
Super Chat thank you brother Xbox One
stock competition that PS wants to run
from bottom line PS is going to get what
it gave to Sega and I'm going to love
every minute of it rules of the game
snitches get stitches I have your own
Supply and I am My Brother's Keeper oh
man let's get it PlayStation wants to
play on the same checkers board and
Microsoft wants to play chess
yeah we got one away dragons once again
five dollar Super Chat Halo is King what
game brings massive friends together
like Halo yesterday and many a game
nights I played in this community great
game nights yeah kills
imagine once a custom games works and we
get forged up in there
that'd be crazy and we got one away once
again five dollar Super Chat King
Spartan is ashy cause he was hiding in
the bush
[Music]
I can't say what I was calling you I
can't say what I was calling you right
now on on live but if y'all want to go
to the stream yeah
and I said I think we'll call it oh yeah
okay so wait we got um from clutchman oh
one the guy next to not only looks like
he would be gone guys
member chat from JD gamer compare the
competition games that Xbox and
Playstation will have in 2023 I believe
that that all those AAA Bankers coming
from Xbox will be a knockout then we got
a two dollar script no more Oscars my
man comes from Wii game No More Heroes
huh okay
all right cool cool I thought you were
trying to get Oscar out of there
I'm talking about um not you I'm talking
about him trying to get over again but
anyway so we gonna move on so look this
is what we here for y'all know what it
is this is the big one it says broke the
internet let's get it um yes made the
rounds very interesting comments to
Bloomberg
what happened I said funny yeah yeah
very very yeah very interested the
internet was definitely broken shout out
to Bloomberg
um yeah he the chief executive
are you Messier executive well he said
he's confident that the company can
regain regulatory approval for 69
billion dollar purchase of Activision
Blizzard even in the face of in-depth
regulatory probe in the UK he said of
course any acquisition of decides will
go through scrutiny but we feel very
very confident that will come out he
said in an interview with Bloomberg
television he said that um as you look
at it he said Microsoft is either the
number four or number five competitor in
the video game industry depending on how
you count and the number one player Sony
group has made several recent
acquisitions so if this is about
competition let us have competition and
that is the segment that people yeah
King He lowkey pointed across the room
he said stop him from snitching
he did he did exactly what we doing
yeah so this is what it is man this is
obviously the the Activision Blizzard
King thing is still running around here
and obviously this is the first time I
would say that's the first time but
Satya in the mix you know with this
situation let's talk about it man let's
get Ken scientists let's do a bit of the
gaming Circle podcast sir so uh what are
your thoughts what do you think about
satya's statements
honestly I thought you know and we you
know you've heard a lot of people
talking about it they're talking
trillion dollar you know big big
trillion dollar energy with his uh his
uh uh his his body language and all of
that you know uh honestly like you know
this this serves to me anyway this
serves to to be to bring great headlines
and all of that but it's really fun for
for us those of us who are who are you
know watching the balls and Strikes and
all of that you know the long and short
of all of this basically it changes
nothing right uh uh Sony's doing what
Sony does and I would be very surprised
if they did anything different right yes
to do this because that's what they do
right and of course Microsoft is doing
what Microsoft does because that's the
game you play and you know the the the
the CMA and the regulatory bodies will
be the ones to make that decision right
to me all of the back and forth is
literally like and I always make this uh
this analogy it's like Ronaldo grabbing
his leg right when the referee you know
what I'm saying like you just got out of
his leg real quick right it's part of
the game if he gets that foul you can
hate on him but he plays play the game
he played the game he's already played a
game is it real is
playing the game it's it's to that
regular up to the referee right to be
like get off your button and if he
doesn't do that
you know yeah you know uh I love hard
deed every time he puts a tweet out
there he asks me adjective to the lion
crying you know all this oh yeah he's
bad boss he's supposed to do you know
he's doing his muscle so I don't I think
it's funny you know I grab the popcorn
and I enjoyed myself dude yes and and I
know well I think that when when when
Satya like spoke the way he spoke he
knew what this would do right because
they're also paying attention to what
people think right it's it's all the the
it's in the realm of public opinion that
it seemingly Sony is is moving needle
right right in when we talk about
regulators and when we start talking
about brass attacks and what's really
going on I have a feeling that as the
the the the CEO of a trillion dollar
company says they are very confident you
don't put yourself out there like that
unless you really are very confident she
said very you know very twice yeah you
know they're very confident right so as
far as the brass tacks of what this will
mean ultimately I don't think this means
anything
right you know they're going to say what
they're gonna say they're gonna you know
there's going to be a lot of that back
and forth but ultimately when it's all
said and done you know I don't think any
of this will move the needle one way or
another it's just hey from what from
what it looked like to me it was like
satya's Satya looked like it was like
you know Phil I appreciate your your
magnanimous approach but maybe the the
public opinion you know the realm of
public opinion wants a little bit of
that heat and that's what he brought
right literally he said exactly the same
thing Phil said only he said it in a
very much kind of 300 pay me some filthy
filthy okay that's all it was you know
you want competition okay
we we've been keeping the the trillion
dollar warchest back there for a while
letting these guys Whittle here you here
you are wanting competition all right
well let me go get the war chest
it seemed more like that but at the end
of the day it's just fun right yeah
we'll see where this is how it goes Lord
attic your thoughts on something is
comments I'm giving my time to King
please please I'm here for King okay
not like that can go first yes okay okay
please type is limited and he's got the
face so let's move what's going on out
here don't ever say I never did nothing
for you King and for these are the
reasons why I love you
you know um
when I heard it when I saw it I got so
many tweets I got so many uh DMS uh it
was it was absolutely nuts you you would
thought that something happened really
catastrophic
it did though
I call him young Odin oh Lord I call him
young Odin you know saying so when Odin
come off the Mountaintop to figure out
what's going on with the little kids
playing around downstairs because he
heard some boy named Jimmy acting up
he said man this is above your pay grade
you don't you don't even got a yacht yet
you need to sit down
you're golden what's what's what's
what's what's happening right now oh I'm
very very confident that the Activision
deal is gonna go through boo
sit down over there with that snitching
that you're doing hashtag stop snitching
bro and let me show you how
real dudes rap and run and move in the
streets
we number four number five depending on
who chart you're looking at
why is number one looking back at us why
is he snitching why why why are you
cause your pockets are funny
[Laughter]
they said if it was about competition
let us have competition so so just just
to clarify King you're saying that they
saying they would be okay they could buy
the same stuff and it was more of a fair
thing they okay as long as the money
right what what what what what I'm
saying is
when this deal go low passes and it's
gonna pass because they're very very
confident in a situation when when when
when a dude that has a yacht looks over
at you and says we're very very
confident that this is happening
that means he knows stuff that you don't
know it's a need to know
he don't know what's going on only y'all
only know what's up all you know is tell
the Brazilians what's going on why all
they know is to tell you you don't back
yourself in the corner there Jim
you got young Odin coming out telling
you if it's about competition let us
have competition so if it's about that
smoke Sim and same energy B once this is
over and we start buying up stuff oh and
we start locking things down don't come
knocking at my door talking about I need
Call of Duty to survive cause we ain't
got nothing
boy if you don't get off my lawn
voice though King
it's not crying it's it's that a
situation right now exactly what they
sound like I don't wreck rats
Satya ain't have none of that ain't
gonna say you he's
doing this to me and we don't Satya sat
there with a smile if it's about this
work let's have it
if you about them hands my man let's go
do this let's go do that salty is the
dude in the courtroom smiling because
he's just gonna pay everyone off he
ain't getting nothing if you want Call
of Duty you better have Game Pass where
you reside see
young Phil is the squabbler
and he he could squabble with anybody
you know why because he got the backing
of the OG yeah
which is rare
so so we're at we're at a point right
now
where they walk in the lock step
Phil don't swing unless Satya said so oh
you understand so
if you got knocked out understand OG
said no
yo all right so I just want y'all to
know I'm very very confident that Call
of Duty
snitching you did you just made yourself
look soft
and it's like I said like you know
get it don't get a twisted like this is
not going to get dero because it's
something that Jim Ryan says on it's
some kind of interview but all I know is
that something happened and Jim Ryan was
the culprit to stop this deal you think
they just could have take that money
that you're obviously gonna lose a lot
of money if you think they're gonna just
take that money and not do nothing with
it like at that point Phil Spencer and
Saudia are going to be very Petty like
you're gonna buy it
PlayStation Fanboys you want this still
to go through because if this still
doesn't go through you're not going to
want to know what happens next they
gonna buy Sony and put a for sale sign
on the door
they're gonna buy Sony and fire Jim Ryan
messy messy
they're not gonna fire him King they're
going they're gonna make him in charge
of the ID at Xbox broke what they're
gonna do is have them um itemized stuff
since he likes
yo you you in charge of itemization yeah
what I don't like
there's dudes on my timeline talking
about now Call of Duty is trash
oh that's the new thing though you dudes
is in that beta right now with your
chest out right talk about we got the
beta
it's over for you once this deal goes
through
I am so happy I saw one dude uh they
don't treat our fans well so I cancel my
pre-order nobody cares B yeah so you
want to die in a hell that's on you
nobody cares B like nobody cared what
you ate this morning nobody cares what
you're gonna eat today uh you implying
that Twitter is not the reflection of
the actual consumers and games because
nobody said you know what since you got
rid of yours I'm gonna get rid of mine
sucks to be you bro
um I get
Jim this is a heartfelt word to you go
apologize
go apologize go apologize for the
snitches don't I take that three years
I'm sorry whatever y'all want to do for
the three years after that I'm cool with
it it's all money that smile that Satya
had on his face yeah it was kind of a
different it was yeah it was it was it
was weird too that was like you don't
know who's waiting outside for you B
I think that that uh what people call it
that um that Super Chat said it all it
was different energy from Satya because
this is a conversation that the CEO
generally doesn't get involved right
these are these are two again the heads
of their respective you know platforms
Within These bigger platforms but at the
same they are subordinates like they are
underneath this guy at the top of the
company yes and he commented on
something that's going on and arguably
their smallest Department the Xbox right
at this point it's still not it's still
not doing comparatively yeah everything
else
and the fact that he what I liked about
it is that and and I I Love Phil but
feels very good at being diplomatic
right he has to be right and he has to
be I'm not knocking him for that at all
he has to be diplomatic so I just said
no no never would have said something
like that no he never would have said
something no at all at all huh not even
to a fault that's his job but he's very
good doing it because he didn't snitch
again because when he when he drops the
A-bomb on you he's like damn where'd
that come from that fail was always that
I always had a knife in his hand he does
it with a smile doctor does it with a
smile no diplomacy
is like what PR gonna tell me what I can
and cannot say exactly and the great
thing about it was this right and he
called out something that's been
bothering me about about the way the
internet's talking about it the way that
um the way that that the Press is
talking about it is that these bad faith
arguments that say Hey Microsoft is
bigger than Sony they can't Sony can't
make these purchases right cool that is
truth but at the end of the day nobody's
talking about the ideologies that are
the same right Sony's been doing this
just on a smaller scale forever and they
will block as much as they can from Xbox
forever if they can so nobody's arguing
that the ideologies are exactly the same
the fact that that that Xbox has a
higher capacity than them to to make
these deals like I said before
and a bomb with a fly killing a flyer
so this is the thing that bothers me
because everybody argues oh it's not the
same and people want people into one
comparison if he has equivalency because
competition is always equivalent
everybody as if the principal is not to
say exactly and the principles aren't
exactly the same and and Sony will Sony
will do petty things to block off things
from Xbox until the cows come home if
they're allowed to do it and and for
years Xbox has allowed them to do it
whether it was because they didn't have
those relationships in Japan whether it
was uh they didn't have the install base
of the place whatever the case may be or
whether it was apathy on the Xbox side
right the Xbox leadership didn't care as
much about it whatever it was the the
dime is termed it is not the same
um
the competition is going to happen on
the terms that it's going to happen
period and too bad if your coffers are
not in there too bad too bad if your
pockets can't get to this yeah but let's
let's stop pretending that the ideology
behind what both of them are doing
the scale I'm sorry the scale you've
been fighting with them all along you're
gonna tell me you never thought this was
gonna happen you're gonna tell me that
they were the Xbox that you've been
battling for the past 20 years was
always just gonna be hitting you with
one hell with it yeah
okay okay you know what it is solved I
think up until now you've never seen
purchases this big and Sony feels left
out because they can't make these parts
they can't make that perfect it's not my
problems
do you think it's an overconfidence of
what happened in the generation before
and they thought it would remain the
status quo and thus this baby have taken
them back a bit as to why the response
to fight for the the the Call of Duty
aspect of this specifically from Sony I
think what it is and we've been saying
it from the beginning and in the update
obviously did not say see it is that
they figure that the status quo console
sales uh first party exclusive they
thought that status quo was going to
still be a hundred percent viable over
whatever Microsoft was doing right and
the thing about it is that Microsoft has
been willing regardless of how much
money they're making on Game Pass losing
on games whatever the case may be what
they came out and they saw the landscape
and they said how do we make ourselves
so appealing to the consumer that you
can't ignore us right and they went and
did everything in their power to give
you the most consumer friendly but they
gave you a cheaper box if you didn't
want to buy the high-end one and they're
giving you a service that you can pay 10
or 15 into and get a whole plethora of
games including AAA games that Sony had
to Pivot at the last minute to try to
match like so so real quick and then you
guys so they do the exact opposite you
paid us more money for this console you
pay us more money for this game and
that's the thing like it just it is it
is hubris because they went in and they
again they earn that high because every
time the Xbox had opportunity to step on
a rake last gen they did it actually and
it was like not until we got the back
compat announcement And We Got Game Pass
did it did the ship start to turn but
prior to that I give it to them but you
always say I I demand wanted you to
correct his cussing you dude
p-i-person no he didn't yeah you
definitely said the S Voice
I'm just tired about the damn hypocrisy
about the argument because it's stupid
and the thing is I think everybody I
think everybody who's arguing it knows
that it's stupid because it's not a
one-to-one comparison but the thing
about it is you can't how could you have
been in competition with these guys that
long and not ultimately thinks that they
would stop snitching at it
but again I'll go back and I'll listen
to it no you're good it was close it was
close but it was too close
so I mean that's it on it if you thought
that no one at Microsoft or Xbox would
figure out the best way to attack you
guys is with their wallet yeah dumb
y'all dumb and you have not looked at
the history of video games and how these
these Ebbs and flows come where when
hubris is at its highest and you stop
seeing the forest for the trees and stop
thinking that and start thinking that
you don't have to compete at the same
level to stay where you are that's what
it is they felt that they could keep the
status quo and be fine at at some point
that changes and Microsoft has done
enough so far this generation to change
that conversation enough or we'll get
into it later where consoles are selling
in Japan
and it's it is a different day and you
and they made the mistake of waiting too
long to counter it right no and now
they're they're on their heels a little
bit yeah and it's going to be again it's
going to be interesting how it gets
handled but at the end of the day stop
the bad faith arguments the ideals are
the same they're both doing the same not
Microsoft's problem and Sony can't hang
one thing that we don't hear anymore
guys and I'm glad is you know Sony used
to buy stuff and people kept saying but
it's homegrown it made sense for them I
don't hear that stuff anymore I don't
hear that stuff anymore I'm praying for
them look somebody just buying stuff
because Sony getting the scratches
listen even the stuff that's homegrown
is they nurture from a very young age
but a lot of that stuff was still
purchased like you if you look closely
like you talk about the naughty naughty
dog was purchased they they grew it into
a different Juggernaut but it's these
bad faith Purity arguments
I got energy like Sony better tuck they
changed
and when you walk down the block don't
look up
I gotta jump it this was fun oh yeah
this was big because
[Laughter]
it was outside I mean this was symbolic
on on a little bit of a level to me
because
um make no mistake this is a clap back
on a public release yeah it was directed
towards directed towards Jim on the on
the inadequate comments and basically it
was kind of like okay let's put this in
perspective because let's be honest
you know Microsoft's doing everything
they can to try to get I wonder PR told
me not to say this it'll be interesting
if if Satya went off the cuff but make
no mistake you know it is Microsoft's
best interest to get in front of it to
be as transparent as possible because
everything all hands are on Deck as far
as the Microsoft mergers and acquisition
teams to get this deal done this is
actually preventing them to do other
things that they want to do so yeah
at the end of the day you know what I'm
saying it's interesting the points yeah
it's interesting that he made I mean the
things that he's saying because he
mentioned a couple of things to put it
in perspective one positioning hey we're
fourth to fifth they're the number one
guys right as far as Gaming revenue and
all of that stuff so that part is a jab
daddy even imagine being the fourth
person in the race trying to tell the
first person he cheated exactly they're
trying to tell him to slow down yeah no
no it's the other way being the first
person in the right trying to tell the
fourth person he cheated yeah and then
the other thing is you know obviously
the fourth and fifth part but also like
hey wait a minute they're just made
three Acquisitions themselves
stay out here buying stuff talking about
what about them exactly so again now
credit everyone's gonna say false
equivalency I get it but
is the principle is the same the
principle that's what people have to
look at the prince just because one
person's pocket can't do what another
person's pocket could do the principle
of doing it still for the most part has
the same intent you know what I'm saying
good guys I just want to ask you a
question let's answer the question right
you open up Mom and Pop's shop on the
corner right you're selling uh pizza and
stuff like that
and um dominoes opens up across the
street
now you've been there the neighborhood
knows you for a long time
are you gonna go bother dominoes
and tell dominoes because Domino's got
more money than you so Domino's can
actually starve you out and hurt you
really bad but you're gonna be nice with
dominoes ain't you but here's the
actually I'm I'm with ksanti on this
like I'm not mad you're supposed to tell
because let me tell you why they have at
the end of the day they have to protect
their stakeholders they understand if
dominoes come out and they have a
superior product or they have it at the
slices at a cheaper price everybody you
gotta buy one get one free oh we out of
here that's right Call of Duty buy one
get one free Slice on Game Pass we're
out of here so we can't let you if
there's a way to tell the government
bodies about this and this could this
could hurt off Pizza aficionados he's
holding me here's the question here's a
question called are you going to the
Channel 6 news with it
listen the job of Jim Ryan is to protect
his stakeholders whether we call a
snitching or not they lose
yes they look at that pizza bunny that
Call of Duty was getting let's be honest
they wasn't producing that slice that
special slice that they had was being
brought to them and they was getting a
profit for it being in a store yeah so
we got to protect this bread that you
trying to take and giving it away for
free over there abdominals we can't have
you do it we can't justify snitching out
here
I thought you didn't do it business is
he's sitting there and say hey man this
dude I went to Brazil and said all this
stuff right you know what he said it's
about competition let us compete and
that's why I gotta respect the real
gotta respect it now here's the thing
because I just said look you over here
complaining about what we gonna do with
this like but you're the number one
pizza Revenue place in this whole place
you sell the most people control the
block we coming in here doing we do let
us do us stop worrying about what we do
we number four number five we not number
one you if you want to compete put some
better slices on the market
to make people come to your store that's
what this is It's been bad because we
give him some rock with our slices
straight up I agree with a role this is
pizza passing this is what it's going
down so look at the end of the day what
I want to say is that at the end of the
day he definitely did the right thing
for a Public Relation standpoint I think
I'm always solve that they have to be
careful because right now Phil we got to
give props to Phil and the team
forgetting brass to believe in gaming on
this level this is why people are very
excited about the Xbox generation for
the series X and S consoles is because
For the First time we're seeing as a kid
says young Odin Odin does not come
outside to talk about gaming period past
Odin's had to be convinced you know what
I'm saying like yo why are we even doing
this we're losing money on the console
or where the where the software we're
the office guys we're the OS guys this
is not convince us to stay in this and
that's the beauty of Phil and the team
through Game Pass which might be one of
his greatest achievements as the head of
Xbox right you know what I'm saying and
getting the financial guys and the brass
to say oh no no we need to compete and
at this time let people forget Xbox one
had like maybe five Studios you know
what I'm saying at one point that was it
man was it that was the the nature
output and people would say yo do they
care about gaming I don't believe and
they had to fight for it so salute to
them for getting brass to get in there
to do what they got to do I'm telling
y'all right now this is my feeling this
person I have no evidence but this is my
feeling right after this deal closes
this is the mistake I feel that somebody
has to be careful of because now
you've essentially poked an upset the
bear who literally has more resources to
do more than you in the space and the
the the the the the perception I get is
when you make a statement like oh
if it's about competition
Let There Be competition
now you have now made a mindset in my
opinion to be even more aggressive
right if this deal goes through buckle
up because I told people it's very very
likely it will yes
be very clear this is the first I know
this is funny and I'm with kids it is
entertaining as hell I'm gonna laugh all
the way because this is literally
console Warrior at some level right so
be prepared that as soon as this deal
goes through
they are about to be extremely
aggressive so Phil even said himself oh
no we're not done we're not done when
they keep mentioning their number four
or five that's an indication to me we
are not done today get ready today it's
gonna be a very different generation
that's all I'm saying I told people from
the very beginning this is cyclical
things do not remain the same you have
to continue to be hungry and in the
spirit of competition right that's what
we want we want Sony to have to have to
do some things okay Microsoft's coming
they're coming we're gonna have to do
this we got to change this up listen and
vice versa people say yo Xbox what are
you doing right what's going on why are
you not in the mix dude you got all this
money don't complain now
don't get don't they say we want all we
want you to compare don't want you be
careful with you because you people said
this oh all I want to show is them to
get in the mix of B now this is it don't
get mad because it's not how you like it
it's not how it's just Purity and this
sacred talk they're going to compete how
they compete you better be ready yeah
that's that's what this is
this can I add one yes please just one
little interjection and that's this one
piece of the puzzle that kind of irks me
just that yeah
they keep saying and and you know we're
looking at the balls and Strikes right
they keep saying oh Microsoft keeps
competing with money that is absolutely
not
Microsoft competes with cloud gaming
Microsoft completes with Cloud saves
Microsoft competes with letting you play
your games on a on a freaking Samsung
fridge
that's why they compete I'm surprised
I'm surprised they haven't argued that
route because there that's really some
place where they can't compete I mean
I'm I gotta say this they are competing
with money because they went out and
they put servers all across the world
yeah absolutely and they knew at some
point in time you was going to come
knocking so when you came knocking you
came with those little nuts and bolts
for trade you came Bartered for those
little chips you came in there with your
little Dusty coin collection and he was
like yo could we use your servers and
you know young Phil looked over at you
was like whatever B put that in the box
and he's like yo I got you man you need
your lights on everything what's the
problem babe what's up you know so
you're sitting down there you know
fellas at the table looking over at you
he's like yeah you know I don't you know
my in my services and we trying to get
the service thing all right so then what
you did you just went to the dude that
you just asked for help from and you
wouldn't tried to snake them in public
right and that like I said the bigger
implications they are a partner with
Microsoft on Azure which is the bigger
play Microsoft is trying to do so again
this gets sticky this gets because it
really disgusting yeah like it gets very
this is going to be very interesting
okay I know you gotta go but I would
love it I know you can I know listen I
just want I want anybody at Microsoft
yes
and
y'all could do whatever
just blame it on King
blame it on me blame it on me
we took all of the
King
we turned off they servers because of
king and you know what I'm ready for all
the smoke on Twitter
it's because of me
you messy man that's what it gets you to
enjoy oh I was trying to sneak in this
series as Drake before you leave oh yeah
um just real quick it's because of King
not IOP because
everybody else plays everything else
they steam other stuff you know
actively on PlayStation 4. or little man
you know in Japan and then obviously the
the handheld because I would love to get
your thoughts real quick because that
was your topic just your quick boss for
you because this is you before
um I told you I told you about little
man y'all told me it was a fluke that
told me it was a joke little man is in
Japan and you can't stop him B you
cannot stop him little man is running
around Japan right now and you cannot
stop him he's the he's he's he's he's
he's the Land of the Rising Sun's
favorite son
he's The Last Samurai
yo that's a good ideology they don't
like you they chose little man move on
go on to another relationship go to
Europe or whatever you want to do little
man rocks this town God bless
it's old it's over I told him three
weeks but I told him when it happened
before they was like oh it was an
anomaly boom it popped up again it's a
trend so you don't tell me it's a fad
but little man is going to continue to
do what little man does and he's running
ripshaw all over you dude all right
you're too slow you can't beat him yeah
let me address King because I was the
the biggest it's oh he's right
[Applause]
since that last podcast we had I've been
keeping up with these things
you say look what she was wrong about
Keith but I I I I'm I'm walking in here
I'm looking down on the ground I even
look in the king and it's just like one
of those things I get close to him like
he was right
I'm sorry real quick yeah you see how
Sovereign
the Logitech jump off
um
everybody keeps saying when is Microsoft
going to make a handheld they don't need
to get in that market they have partners
that can actually do those things fair
enough right so what they did was they
they knew that uh Logitech was making
this
and you know Nvidia got on board uh Xbox
got on board with Game Pass
the biggest scariest thing with that
whole thing is 10 cent and then put
their fingers involved we'll be coming
out with one people have to get be ready
because 10 cent made the um did they do
something with the OS or something like
that they pretty much have a big hand in
this handheld
um
um that's kind of weird to me because
when I saw the whole thing I was like
especially Sean Leighton over there now
yeah and Sean Layton is over there and
shout out to Jabari and them they had
them on their show like yesterday they
got they picked up yeah they picked up I
want y'all to know
the bridges that you burn is those
Knuckles that you earn oh
all right
Sean gone
he went with a bigger dude now
and this dude wants the space that you
in
and I think 10 cents like number two
in common yeah so I thought they were
number one I thought Sony was I think
Sony's number one in Revenue oh okay
what happens when 10 when when when Sean
looks over and says
they did me crazy
they did me crazy he is kind of right he
is kind of right there I'm not gonna lie
you you make people people could say
that their past won't influence their
future decisions but we all know if he
has got some dirt on someone
I'm applying I'm applying with King 100
I'm saying this
y'all are starting fights
with dudes with bigger bank accounts
than you
what the hell is your problem
does your ego and is your hubris
I cannot wait to the tents to fold up I
cannot wait and I know I know dudes is
like King is Never Gonna fold up y'all
told me Xbox will never win in Japan you
told me Microsoft will never make a
turnaround in this generation it will be
the same exact thing y'all will be
selling at a three to one ratio
young Phil squabbled up and said hell to
the no
and then young Odin looked over and said
who's that young squabbler down there
who's that in the gladiatorial readers
back I also told you God Awards come out
2022. yeah
you know um you think you try to be nice
now to get knees you ain't getting them
um continue but
this this
that I'm seeing
when you put the wrong people in charge
we had
a couple of wrong people in charge
before and it almost sunk our ship
you sunk out Battleship remember that it
did sink it I would say they had to
build a new ship yeah and young Phil
came through and got his name Phil
Dominus Maximus Aurelia Spencer is the
first of his name and you will remember
it he's leaving Footprints in the Sand
you will remember his name because this
is the dude that did it to you for capua
Sega
is gonna come home
after this deal is done
if if if if young Odin says you know
King always right I agree with them
let's get this going if if if you want
competition let us have competition that
means he got ducks in a Roby that means
he already got a line on something that
he's going after as soon as this is done
he's running straight across the street
and he's throwing a brick stack of money
that's something that you want that you
can't afford and King I you know I will
say that I have been turned by some
little little fishies that you know uh
the the Asian market that that whole
Market is the next Target
I will love that and I will move to the
Land of the Rising Sun
a lot of this stuff and put that up and
have fun with that yes we have to do a
podcast live in Japan
man let's get to these topics for
everybody else's thoughts on those same
words like the king does his day looking
inside team man
so um yeah you know series that's a
little combo topic um the series that
sells in Japan like they are still doing
well I just want to give a little
additional context to it um so pretty
much shout out to uh famitsu and um yeah
they brought out the the the sales
numbers as far as um still switch OLED
doing this thing 96 000 you know what
I'm saying and then um switch uh regular
25 000 that week and switch light 4 000
and then here comes the series S Series
S ahead of the PlayStation 5 and the
PlayStation 5 digital and then the
series X underneath that and then I do
want to give a caveat because we have to
be fair and accurate so it looks like
shout out to Genki at TGs and this is in
conjunction with the fermental report
the main one of the main reasons that
Xbox is offering they had this special 5
000 Yen coupon with the series s Japan
until the end of month that coincided
with the PS5 price increase that
recently went up so so why
so did it say about the price increase
or it was that they timed it at the same
time Sony's bf5 price increase so
they're not down thirty dollars they
went up 5500 again PlayStation 5 in
Japan and then Series S low admit a
special coupon for five thousand yet
less five times again less oh that's
that's 30. that's dirty at least that
was in the mix so yeah they said since
then they said the series that sells
unit shot up you know from 284 units to
Pride week to 13
200 units that week I would like some
marketing like that over here
well remember North America there is no
price increase for PlayStation 5 so
remember everything can we get some of
that marketing over here but um yeah I
just wanted to add that that caveat to
it so um ksanti man what are you
thinking about the series as part of
this first yeah I know I think it's it's
it's very interesting that what series s
has been doing in this market I I am one
who has stood with little man for a long
time some of my my uh friends and and
colleagues have not been so fortunate
and so having the foresight that I have
had oh you called it and I said well
it's still coming like I don't I don't
think you're seeing the full
ramifications of what series s will do
um
in that way right so what you're pretty
much saying is the series s isn't at its
final four yeah I agree with him at some
level and he is not in his final form
cell is not in his final form okay
Series S when someone out here that
understands anime I didn't know what the
hell he was talking about but continues
so it's like right now right and we all
know it right for various reasons right
whether it be whether it be covet or
anything else the the the the eighth gen
is not leaving us right it's just it
keeps sticking around with 8th gen comes
a specific way of development right
where you know the more resources you
have the more you can do that's it right
this is a gym situation you go you lift
you lift your arms your arms get
stronger that's it you don't do that you
don't do it that's not where Series S
shines because Series S will never
outshine the higher end machines right
but if we live in a world where they
have cut bait with it with the the the
older processors and the older mindset
of development right Series S has a lot
of interesting tricks that helps them
uplift and and close the gap on on where
their their strengths are missing right
so to me when they start developing that
and and every time I start speaking this
way I always have to give Microsoft a
little smoke I'll just go smoke because
because it's not your fault consumer for
downplaying the series s it's not your
fault for clowning him it should have
been up to them maybe I don't know maybe
take uh something like a a hive Busters
make it Miles Morales like separate
thing and put some energy into it and
show the people what series s can really
do so even if you don't see it again
from another four or five years it's
full capabilities you at least have
something to point to nobody has
something to point to with the series s
so when you clown it you clown IT and
those techies like us who go hey on
paper this thing is a killer you need to
keep your eyes on it that's all we got
right you can't point to something that
goes see this is how it outshines the
rest but it can
looks absolutely phenomenal the first
time that you you opened your eyes and
went okay is when you saw like flight
Sim Running Oh yes yes you know what I'm
saying like everyone knows okay like
that became the way to play fights him
the cheapest right because before then
it was a monster rig like monster rig
and then as soon as they did that in the
series s was oh my God it's amazing then
they even went even further and went
cloud gaming you can play that thing on
a toaster that's neither here nor there
right but Series S is out here it's just
never been able to to have the
opportunity to shine the way it was
built so you know so I've always been
like look while you're out here and then
of course we have chip shortages
that make Series S
far more more of an interesting option
for people than than the series X and or
the PlayStation 5 or whatever so I've
always thought the series S as a machine
is very interesting very it's great that
they that they they chose to skew it the
way they did right there's there there
is valid criticism about memory uh the
memory bandwidth that they they chose to
allocate to it and all of that but even
with that said
when you look at what this thing is
capable of there is a world where you
know three four five years on the line
that is the reference design for most
games going forward because it is a
perfect entry point into the next gen
right so I've always been confident that
it can it can definitely succeed you
know it's just
you know show me something that that
shows it off right and even now they
haven't really done that right they
haven't really been like this is why you
want a series that's hey this is still
next gen you know uh while third parties
some kind uh use it as a it seems and
I'm I could I'm probably wrong but it
seems that it becomes an afterthought
sometimes oh well all these things got
this feature Series S didn't get it oh I
see what you say okay you know what I
mean like it seems they don't spend
enough time on there so I personally
think Microsoft knowing that this is
your baby this is literally what they
did with surface they got sick and tired
of people clowning windows and they went
see this is how it should look you want
to go buy an HP device if they're not
doing this don't don't hate on us right
because this is how it should be
honestly I'm with you on one part the
other part I know where you go with the
tech I'm hold on I'll push back a little
bit on the attack but I'm I'm with you
in the sense of the because they killing
me like [ __ ] does not understand the
final four reference I don't watch
Dragon Ball Z bro I'm sorry well um but
at the end of the day like I do agree
that it hasn't reached its final form
because to me I think it's going to be
when Game Pass is at its height whether
the Apex starts it starts to rise and we
look at it activism blizzard kick deal
and you have Call of Duty running on
that system with like butter like butter
right and now they're like hey Game Pass
and you could walk out of here right now
with this 300 device and you can have
this whole library with one of the
number one Shooters in the game that's
when I'm with you that they need to be
you know talking about this from the
rooftop I need to be right now though
not right now but I need to see what
like I need to see or like the OverWatch
the Diablo the the Call of Duty console
the marketing has to be on point because
if you use that then there's like oh
okay
yeah and then when that starts happening
then third parties will start cheating
it like an afterthought absolutely then
you will start those feet you'll start
seeing those let's be let's be
absolutely 100 here right to get ray
tracing and all those quote unquote
next-gen features running on the series
s takes more work than the series X and
oh for sure PlayStations equivalent for
sure and that's why by and large you see
those features left off of the series s
right but if it becomes the definitive
Source when you start seeing it
everywhere right folks will start taking
the time and the resources and the
energy necessary to make that little box
shine absolutely right now it's not in
its final form but it's still it's still
out here and I'm still really happy to
see where it's yeah and we haven't even
talked about the the prospect of but we
don't know if we'll get a mid-gen
refresh or anything like that I'm sure
we'll get some kind of console redesign
for both the X and the S at some point
right yeah so my thing is like even
let's say you make the series that's
even smaller right wow and it and and
change the inner
to make it maybe if there is some sort
of Med console refresh you up the ante
on the X and at the same time of the NT
on the S and make the S closer to what
an X is now and you and you raise that
base level even higher to make it even
that much more important so when you
talk about omitting Ray tracing and
stuff like that maybe you reach a
baseline where you don't have to do that
right and you're still hitting that
1080p that 1080p uh resolution but
you're hitting that 60 FPS with all the
bells and whistles and and then you
couple that with uh with cod in there
and all this stuff and Game Pass so to
me stocking stuff for Call of Duty costs
a series s theme all the box then we
ain't even talk about if they decide
yeah and that's the thing and if that
happens right and if that happens let's
say it does the old let's say let's say
if there's a refresh or there's a
refresh whatever the case may be but you
do re reach that that impulse by yeah
listen I'm sorry I'm gonna do it right
back to you the fact that they are even
playing around in Japan right now with
the the coupon price that when these
when they were Sony raised the price get
ready like they they're they're testing
the market over there to see what's
working and when it comes over here it
could get interesting continue
I actually feel like 300 it's already
impulse pot you go lower than that like
we're talking like because I feel like
it impulse buys something that you'll
question but you'll buy it you know what
I'm saying like it's not something you
have to sit there and like internally
fight with yourself at Walmart like it's
at that point we're like all right you
know I can mess with this but I think
like like you want to get to that point
where people just don't feel that they
don't feel uncomfortable with it like
okay I'll get that that quality and look
I've said this over and over again Call
of Duty marketing is most the time more
effective than the actual games
themselves for each and I don't think
people understand and they can't
mentally understand that what's gonna
happen when Microsoft fully takes over
that marketing is you're going to see
stuff like you're gonna see uh the
market the series s with Call of Duty
like simultaneously
and the Casual guys gonna say oh this is
where I go and then I don't know how the
marketing works for Esports and all that
but there's there's a lot of components
to this you know and if they're able to
hit ever to hit that 200 price point too
I would I would start thinking about
packing in that screen
you show that to a 10 year old like oh I
can take this with me and the reduction
of the offline
um
and making it playoff friendly to play
offline they got a lot of potential here
I'm with y'all there's there's still
more to go for this is best for it for
it to do what I got to do but I wanted
to get that part all I said anywhere got
any more bars on Series S and and that's
what I think you're gonna see the series
as
absolutely explode when that Call of
Duty does happen like I just we live in
this bubble and I love this bubbles I
don't care about it
like people sit their attic you have to
take other people's you know gaming
habits no I don't know
it's like look like just because but if
you if you do consider this bubble in
the bubble that we live in
there's a bigger World outside this
bubble and the majority of the people
that that are out of this bubble they're
the ones that's playing those games like
when people say oh you know Call of Duty
sold 150 million uh or I think it's a
ridiculous number that they've all sold
do you honestly think that the majority
of that was because they bought it for a
platform no they bought it because it
was the easiest accessible thing they
can get their hands on and you're about
to add something even more accessible
that the that the markets never had and
it's already being successful without
this no absolutely it could get it could
get real interesting very quick the
second part I definitely want to mention
was what king talked about is the
Logitech G handheld device so we got to
talk about it briefly
um yeah shout out to Xbox they came on
statement play Halo infinite def a
little bit more with Xbox cloud gaming
on the Logitech G handheld so they're
announcing it looks like it would be
launched North America on October 17th
and uh this just a bit of a spec sheet
with it you know say it looks like seven
inch handheld uh HD 1080p screen 12 hour
battery life and lightweight portability
and um then they also go into the um I
should look at the spec of detail it
looks like the basic bells and whistles
you know Snapdragon 720 octa-core and um
Bluetooth Wi-Fi all the all the basic
stuff that you would expect for this
also haptics and things like this of
that nature so want to bring it to the
realm stop I can't stop there I heard
you talk about it on the gaming Circle
podcast what are your thoughts of this
what do you want to call it a
partnership what do we want to call this
case I would call it a partnership I
guess yeah I would call it a partnership
and and to to uh to King's Point uh um
um if I'm if I'm not mistaken 10 cent
made the UI because every time they show
you the UI they show you the UI based on
what Microsoft based on the Xbox's uh
interface but to my understanding
there's an earlier interface that gives
you the choice of what whether it be
Game Pass OR Nvidia or whatever yeah and
they have an interface there that was
envy that was a 10 cents contribution so
they create the interface that allows
you to choose which one you want you
want yeah uh as far as this device is
concerned I think it's awesome I'm very
happy that that they're they're in this
market uh I'm I've kind of this is kind
of uh not an answer but more in the line
of this guy right here right but like I
I took I I took my daughter to the
barber shop a couple days ago and I had
to give her this and you know shut her
up for a while while I was getting my
haircut and the whole time she's holding
this thing in her hand and I'm just like
so in that world like a light portable
lightweight device that that you can
just hand her hey play these games oh
yeah that's absolutely great my only
only concern talk about it and I know
people talking about it I'm not you know
people will will this conversation about
value for dollar will continue to happen
oh for sure my perch is from the
technical place because that's where
I've always kind of felt comfortable
right
look it up there's a thing called the
xiaomi redmi note 9 Pro it is basically
a mid-tier Android device from 2017
2018. something like that literally spec
for spec this device
actually that device has more RAM and
you can buy it for like 240 dollars and
it comes with LTE radios so then you can
just swipe your SD your sim card in
there and you got everything you need
and then your response will be well it
doesn't have the right and the left cool
controllers and then to that I will say
Razer or backbone right all of that
together will make the same price point
right my problem is because for reasons
valid reasons of course well you know
and arguments can be made that this is
not a Microsoft produced device uh um
it's not subsidized by the manufacturer
the cost has to be you know they have to
make some kind of profit so that's why
the cost may not be
if it was subsidized if it was because
because the specs that we're looking at
here specifically to this device is like
a buck 50. that moves yeah at most the
buck 50. they're coming in at three yeah
don't get me wrong I'm excited for it I
am because I know what that that
Snapdragon uh 720g can do you know you
know and and you know the the views
represented by KSI do not represent do
not do not represent the iron Lord yes
that is correct I'm glad you said that
kid I'm a proponent of of of keeping
games alive if you own your game you can
emulate it wherever the heck you want
they won't like it but you can do that
because it's legal this thing can play
everything up to PS2 right everything
right offline
so you're at that dentist you don't have
that Wi-Fi connection hey maybe you
throw in a game of some kind whether
whichever game that may be so all of
that to me is valuable right so I'm
excited to check this out it's just for
someone who's not me for just an end
user like myself and Mr Boomstick you
know we chat on The Daily you know I was
talking to him he initially was had a
steam deck pre-ordered but after I told
him it's tinkering nature he opted not
to do that because not everybody's about
that yeah some people want it just
they're ready to go they don't want to
join it yeah this would be the solution
for them it's just I'm just I wish it
was more stocking stuffer Price
Right I'd be excited to recommend this
to people I've already gotten a bunch of
DMS from people going oh bro you know
when I get that I'm gonna be hollering
at you for for some toodling I got you
you know I'm excited I want to do it I
just want this thing to be a no-brainer
you know if you are a staunch
PlayStation user you've never been about
Xbox at all this should be something you
should pick up for like a buck night for
for like 99 or a 150 with a Game Pass
subscription real quick and this could
be your side hustle to to get you into
this new ecosystem it's an interesting
cool thing that we should be excited for
but that price needs to you know that
price needs to talk about that you know
and that's even that price at 299. at
350 get the heck out of here what's
wrong with you get out of here but uh
that's that's my thoughts no doubt no
doubt look at it the king of the
handheld Market
um very you stand with the Logitech G
x-cloud receiving handheld device
no salt can have that just like
this is
remotely interested but uh oh boy uh you
know our guest just completely destroyed
that
you got the information so just real
quick though because I need to know what
is the deterrent what is the thing that
was like oh no I can't I need to know
I feel like if you're gonna pick
something up like this you might as well
just buy steam duck
um
yeah I don't
I don't now obviously see the reason
like handhelds has always worked with me
yeah is because like I play like Pokemon
and stuff like I've always felt like the
only way and keep in mind I don't even
play a lot of games like I have my
switch and most of the time when I'm
playing on my switch it's like I'm still
on my TV so it's just like
it I just personally feel like
you have to make games that make it
sense to be mobile like first person
shooters like to me you're not gonna sit
down and play Call of Duty online with
your boys like yeah I I just don't see
that happening like mobily like that
um you know I see you know stuff like
Persona Pokemon that's the reason that
my that's the reason Nintendo's been
able to dominate so long because they
understand their Market they look at
something like the Switzerland okay
we're gonna make games that make sense
when you're on the Move most of them you
can't Paul most of them you don't you
could pause because they know that you
know stuff comes up you can pause it and
they're like and then it's gonna have
these offline components these online
components that you can do that's why I
feel like the the Vita messed up because
V because PlayStation was trying to
treat the Vita like a mini console not
like a portable console is it trying to
get like Lost Legacy and uh and
Borderlands and it's just like and then
you got Nintendo over here making RPGs
making race sirs that you could pause
you don't have none of this fast Twitchy
stuff going on and you see stuff like
that going and it's there's a reason
Nintendo has been Keen for so many years
you know what I will push back on one
piece I hear you and you're 100 right
but I think that may change soon I
suspect Nintendo has been lucky because
Hardware has never been that capable of
giving you a real next like console
experience on a handheld so Nintendo
never even bothered trying everybody
else that tries it's a pale imitation of
what real gaming looks like but more and
more that handheld thing is getting
closer and closer to console quality
like steam deck isn't 100 there but it
is the closest it's ever been yeah I
don't like seamless I play cyberpunk
2077 on this thing for some hours yeah I
can't do it on switch their argument may
have all of a sudden just changed right
it for a long time now it's been that
way but for now if you can successfully
play cyberpunk on this thing for a while
and it works and and I get you on the
positive thing 100 agree but they've
been lucky because they're like look
gameplay is King we don't need to we
have an abacus
right it works but all of a sudden now
people out here you know giving you like
stuff that can transcend like console
the things you're used to in a handheld
yeah that might start changing the
narrative for people I think maybe I
don't know I
the reason I don't like the steam deck I
don't like the layout of the control
like the actual hand like it it seems
like like way up here when you when you
play it for a while you get used to it
and it feels great I'm not trying to I
get used to it yeah
I can't I can't with his resistance to
just minor things it's like it's not
even that I think you get used to it you
I'm completely with you it looks weird
but the moment it touched my hands and I
was in this it's fine yep I was wrong
it's fine perfect
sure right
your passion to play stuff Mobley has
cloudy
your head up Xboxes you know what oh my
God
[Laughter]
it's just like you know and I don't even
play the games I have now mobile very
often yeah he doesn't do it unless he
has to yeah he's like force yeah and
plus most the time if I'm playing
something on the switch most likely I'm
reviewing it so it's got to be hooked up
to to my computer so I can actually do
it it's just like I don't have a hatred
for mobile I probably played more Mobile
gaming than all of you my my issue is
just I got to the point where mobile
didn't fit me as a player that's what
cake is at right now yeah
um and I will say attic to your point
the reason mobile fits me now is because
you know I I have a five-year-old I have
a three-year-old I'm not sitting in
front of a PC I'm not sitting in front
of my console and even if when the
chances I do I'm not playing anything
that I want to play because God forbid
they see daddy shooting somebody's head
off that's not cool
you know Alden ring fix oh yeah stop
deal with the kids oh I'm doing
something stop deal with it and this
becomes the way I I end up gaming far
more because I can get that console
quality and believe it or not even
through so pass oddly I play a lot on
this thing so that's what it works for
so just to clarify because I don't know
a whole lot like I know some things I
say on the Twitter like so I could play
like Eldon ring right now on the steam
to um better than your PC yeah 60 frames
yep it'll run better than your PC yep
but then again on those medium settings
point though the only reason why that
Medium setting doesn't matter is you're
not discounted big old OLED right so
those small screens the smoke the smoke
effects that you made medium you won't
even see it the yep
and then you apply FSR you apply FSR and
you can run it at an even lower
resolution but still have the bells and
it'll upscale it yeah you think it's
great just a number brother like he
doubt about it
so if you're not a tinkerer by nature
and you want things to be out the box
not double sorry I left PC yeah I'm not
into troubleshoot games
that g uh the Logitech G is perfect for
you it's just that darn price point
because like ever born for instance he
uses this exclusively for Game Pass like
he plays xcloud just like this and you
know people are like oh well you want
that device because it lasts longer if
you limit the Watts on this yeah you can
do the Game Pass yeah it'll be cool
awesome yeah just like just the other
one right it's just that's what he does
and for that use case and you're never
going to Tinker that device is
absolutely I am excited for it's perfect
you just gotta you know they gotta yeah
work on that price point yeah
I look at this device oh I'm sorry
I I just Googled does Elder and Rain run
at 60 frames on Steam day it says in big
bold letters
you could even use the steam deck 40
Hertz mode to lock a smooth 40 and a
half PS in many titles included
with the correct
so you may need to tell me that I have
to make tweaks and it still might not
run 60 frames it would does it because
40 okay there's the 40. the 40 FPS 40
FPS at that resolution and screen size
is akin to running at 60 at a higher
resolution it's the screen size the
screen size really does I'm so if you
look at the switch this the switch
doesn't they didn't think about this
right and it obviously the switch is an
old machine but a lot of My Hope Is that
a lot of these little bells and whistles
that the steam deck has is incorporated
and how they're able to push the
whatever the second iterational switch
is to to to be more capable of running
modern games 40 FPS at that screen size
feels like 60. straight up yeah and and
actually to your point to your points of
like if and shout out to digital Foundry
love their stuff always watch their
stuff Spider-Man on PC came out people
were doing the reviews on this if you
check their reviews there are frame
rates everywhere going crazy oh it can
barely run for some reason nobody went
oh yeah limit the frame rate to 40 FPS
okay let's it is this it's like this
it's just perfect quality yeah but they
don't show you that because you have to
hit the button to put that in before the
FPS mode
I'm
gonna stay on my PC
you get your Logitech and then you play
it through the clouds
we know I think we got the same
on this yeah let's move on so yeah for
me I look at this product and I think on
live I look at this product and I think
oh yeah
there are things that are it's either
ahead of its time or too late yeah good
point and I look at this and I think
it's a product that is ahead of its time
I just because I gave you two products
one day with ahead of his time when it
was like oh okay okay
and I look at this and it is the former
it is a product that I feel is ahead of
its time because
we don't yet have the infrastructure to
support this side ubiquitous Wi-Fi there
we go the infrastructure doesn't exist
to support it
so that literally you can walk anywhere
with it and you can have a connection
right
um we don't have we still haven't
reached that point where where input lag
and stuff like that across the board is
acceptable so this is uh from nearly 400
product that you essentially expect
people to use in their homes
right
and nowhere else and then move from
place to place that has that level of
Wi-Fi to be able to use it it does not
make a whole lot of sense in the
landscape as the landscape stands now
now do I believe that they're the
products like this have to come out to
get the ball rolling and to have to be
the sacrificial lamb to get there yes
um and in in that regard it doesn't
surprise me that Xbox is on board with
it because again they've taken the
punches up front to to sort of get to
even this point so the fact that they
need to
associate themselves with a product
that's going to allow it to continue to
get to that finish line does not
surprise me as a commercial product it's
it to me it's going to be a failure and
I think they know that they're not dumb
they know that but the ball has to
continue to roll you can't stop because
if you stop then the entire idea of
cloud starts to wane right and if that's
your future you can't Microsoft yeah
Microsoft themselves will probably
bankroll that before they let that
happen precisely right so this is a
product that has to exist and has to die
in order for the next step to happen
like one of those vicious nature shows
for anonymity for the food chain
Revolution
survival of the fittest and it has to
happen because when you look at it there
the all the alternatives are better like
like someone can say the same thing that
the Sega had to die before you
I mean the Sega Sega died see the thing
the problem with Sega is this Sega never
had the money to compete with a Nintendo
they don't have the call for us to
compete with a Nintendo or a PlayStation
one PlayStation jumped into the mix
ultimately they they were never going to
be able to compete at that level Beyond
a certain point it just wasn't gonna
happen so uh it you know besides the
fact that they imploded and they killed
themselves in a lot of ways they
probably exited earlier than they would
have because of that they weren't able
they were not going to be able to
compete with a Sony and and a Nintendo
that was very much willing to spend
their money it just wasn't going to
happen so but this is different because
this
to me it is that thing of tencent
doesn't care about how much money you're
going to lose on this because they're
they're getting the they're getting the
tentacles in right Logitech is all over
the place this is just another product
again this is not going to hurt them if
it fails this is not going to be a
headline that's like oh my God Logitech
and remember they're not getting no
bread off of no kick like they're not
getting no off of the um I bet yourself
the subscription stuff like right I
would say that that may be that may be
mistaken because the backbone offers
subscriptions you hey have 30 days of
game pass this and that from all these
other manufacturers and they do get a
kickback backbone does they get it back
your subscriber so it seemingly is the
same here I mean obviously we don't know
the the injury but you think that if
backbone gets a kickback for getting you
into game pass through backbone probably
the the G tab will probably also I'm
curious about the same kind of thing you
know what I mean but but your point
Sovereign like one thing you said that
just kind of kicked it in for me and I'm
just like that is actually a very good
point that would have solved this whole
thing that Snapdragon 720g is built with
LTE radios that is how it's built that's
how Qualcomm builds all of them so you
manufacturer must have gone to Qualcomm
and said yeah give me that 720g but rip
off radio right the thing that we need
to basically fill in the gaps of right
taking this elsewhere why didn't you
enjoy it yeah that is great it's built
with it you don't give me the option of
having some sort of data plan on there
so I can at least get get get the the
feeling of it being fluid anywhere that
I go right and and I know that's got an
old school idea when you think about the
Vita having it and all that stuff but
again it's the option so again what's
scary to me about this is that the the
overall Optics won't be good my hope is
that it's just buried enough that it
doesn't matter and it doesn't become a
big deal where people start really
saying oh this this idea isn't going to
work and I don't think I don't think
that is the case but again I just think
there's so many when you look at the
Alternatives is another thing right you
look at for a lot of people you look at
the switching block off whatever I get a
switch right or you look at the 350
price tag and you look at it uh the base
steam deck is four hundred dollars a
device that will do all of this it will
do all of the streaming for you in
addition to having native games playable
and play and playable well so it's just
I don't know who it's for I get the idea
that it has to be out there I saw Phil
standing next to Kojima with it whatever
and I'm sure Kadima looked at it but
like okay let's let's see what we can do
with this I mean kojima's kojima's game
is very you know supposed to be very
Cloud oriented right so you want access
for as many people as possible I don't
know who this is for right now and again
for me it's definitely not for any of us
wait for the price drop wait for the
inevitable 199. like you said at 99 yes
yes so I can sit on the throne and play
sure yeah oh sorry I can't stop it no
that's it that's a different but again
anything above that no yeah my thoughts
are kind of exactly time it was solved
and it's just like his dick and I want
to love it detecting me because he wants
to love this like the problem is I look
at it and I say okay the build quality
looks great the design looks fire I love
that they are doing almost like say a
custom UI where they're allowing the
different streaming platforms and then
also the big thing that I did not get
enough credit for is a long Remote Play
into your that's a feature that nobody
else can no one else is doing it to do
that that's hard to do that let's see if
they can do it before we say I mean Xbox
is working closely with them so clearly
you know they most likely figure this
thing out and to me Remote Play When I
had video that was one of my favorite
features I would literally remote into
my PlayStation while I was at work
supposedly doing Tech stuff but I was
focused on sometimes looking at the
feeder and what's going on my
PlayStation and that was a that was a
really cool feature because what happens
is then I helped reduce some latency
because I do my home connection was
connected to whatever it was and it was
lit you know so I it was a great feature
so the way I look at this is that
it's kind of a half step in a sense for
Microsoft they're not willing to fully
commit in themselves and they're like
okay Logitech you do this and I do think
there's a part of them that they're
going to sit there and analytically
watch to see what they're going to check
the Telemetry that comes in how many
exactly
who's playing and two of them now I'm
with addict this ain't for me I'm a
steam that guy you know my problem is
just like solves at the price point bro
like you being that it's a streaming
only device right like bro I literally
have the key sheet right for 99. I could
do the same thing theoretically minus
the remotely with my Kishi and my phone
I get it with data if you need it with
data you know what I'm saying that's the
thing so it's like and let's be honest
as a handheld part of the Allure is
being able to play anywhere that means
you are now at the mercy of whatever hot
spot at Starbucks you at oh you know
like let's be real in the infrastructure
of these places are generally not good
so now it's a paperweight on a plane
it's a paperweight where you don't have
that's where the switch is still winning
people can say what they want about the
graphical Fidelity switch but if I go on
it oh yes few people are skilled issue
okay like you are a tech company
I'm just saying like they could have
kind of and they they are pushing that
whole hey it also has uh the the the the
the Google Cloud Google uh Services yes
so you could do the Android stuff and
that's offline stuff absolutely
absolutely and that part that does give
you that I just like I said I think like
soft said it beautifully in order for us
to get to where we got to go these kind
of devices have to exist no they have to
exist and I'm with that and it looks
like a phenomenal I want to be very
clear it really looks cool it's just
what I think was the price point because
at 300 349
I'm in the same pocket as a series s
right and same positive switch like it's
just if you would have came in at 199
you know what I'm saying like that 100
Sweet Spot yeah that that's where I'm at
with it and I just think that you know
eventually we will get there and the
last part I wanted to say is that the
reason why the native thing listen I
know shot the battery place we go at it
all the time he's like yo why don't they
make a native device I don't understand
I understand and the only point I would
say is that when people have to
understand is that that's another Hall
rescue that you specifically have to
have devs developed for
like all of that all of that and I don't
think at this point that is in alignment
with the metal term vision of Microsoft
I don't want them to even focus on
something like that get your house get
your house that's where I'm at the
long-term vision of Microsoft is
actually this as far as Azure streaming
and stuff like that so look
the last one I say because I want to be
fair to it they are doing very well with
their streaming and they're um like we
saw the fortnite data how much people
stream that that blew me away like this
it's amazing it's amazing so I will say
this and I'll go because I I am not a
connoisseur in all these other regions
they may look at the data and there may
be regions that this appeals to as an
interest this is one pill to an American
audience right and I'm looking selfishly
as Carl because cog's American and he
don't want you know but at the end of
the day if there's a region where they
look at that Telemetry and they say yo
this is doing well here then expect the
more iterations and then hopefully Xbox
themselves make uh one that actually the
price was a little lower whatever but
it's an entry point that's how I look at
it so I just wanted to say that so I'll
just get the super chat today
so you are muted you're muted
yeah because once again this is wilding
out in the Bronx
I love the face on people when they when
they find out they're muted well it's
like that oh God yeah why I mean why are
you getting it in order I can read the
um the what you call is the merch
say some Birch cables yeah
um
yeah we got it okay cool go go for it go
for it Christopher Hart five dollar
Super Chat Microsoft does not want to
play in chess they want to play steel
from Nintendo and so whoops did I say
that hey whatever whoops did I say that
Miracle voice
we got C wubby you two dollar Super Chat
I need a fighting game with the
PlayStation 5 and Xbox I think that's
what he meant yeah and we got splend
difference remember for six months two
dollars Super Chat lying crying them
dropping banana in the tailpipe Ryan oh
my goodness
many many superlatives uh Italian clouds
Satya took off the gloves Ryan's only
outspoken to pretend he's doing
something because he can't stop it yeah
you can't really stop it like you know
then we got Hot Grits 9 10.
yeah it's sad seeing a Thug Cry tighten
up Sony the streets just watching wow
then we got Mass Iraq remember for one
year five dollar Super Chat I need an
Xbox fighting game with Microsoft and
Sony exec Satya would be throwing money
bags instead of fireballs yeah
then we got gaming times Patrick
remember for one year five dollars with
chat King is hilarious and everything
you said was true Satya had different
energy it was like his company was worth
trillions or something
that is true that's true now we got
black Ronin 357 remember for 17 months
stop spitting big facts right now
satya's coming to play and put big money
behind his mouth but he did
then we got awful Grim bones five dollar
Super Chat shout out to the Lords these
shows are good for the soul I'll be
working I'll be at work listening and
can't finish the building on time
finished stay focused on the mission
though we love them we love support yeah
the mission's watching us
advocating games
then we got the way to turn the five
dollar Super Chat yo Jim make sure you
keeping your mouth shut when grown folks
is talking yeah that's kind of how that
felt yeah that's true true oh he got the
homie Gerald Max remember for 24 months
looking back Sony has never had real
competition I get it finding out you
have to fight is is new still a Sony
still it's Sony's problem all hell the
ILP salute salute I mean if you think
about it all right obviously Nintendo
was out in the streets but uh Sega was a
non-starter with the with the Saturn
when it came today and do all right I
feel you on that but we can't do up
doing look there's back there
no no no I was Hunger because they came
off the PS3 and 360 was outside they was
in this world yeah so they've had to
fight that is for sure
then we got awful Grim bones once again
two dollar Super Chat happy birthday to
boom I wouldn't have found y'all without
him the boom stack so y'all hit him up
with that birthday shout and then we got
Doug remember for nine months that's
believe I can't wait to listen on the
Lord's day when the deal goes through
the chat's gonna be crazy on that dude
it might be interesting
yeah yeah that day that day's gonna be
funny yes and we have Deus Ex machiado
the first IOP after God of War comes out
some of us would love personally to
bring back the so-called Pizza we have
Microsoft today I actually had yes she
loved me yeah they got the recipe yeah
let's see maybe one of these games we'll
see we got C W once again two dollar
Super Chat King please share those Xbox
checks with the eye with the IOP crew
it is
we got DJ auros member for one year five
dollar Super Chat happy Sunday realm
hashtag Hey besties
man salute to him man good dude then we
got Raiden blade remember for one year
two pound Super Chat Cog did you swat
swallowed star whoa I feel not addicted
I remember his last week he asked you to
watch oh yeah it's the name brother it's
just the name
I don't know
you know it's crazy the amount of people
that was asking Cognito to watch certain
fights and animals in the comments
section last night I was wow I saw so
many gar versus uh Rock Lee things in
there
no doubt then we got uh Hot Grits nine
ten five dollars Super Chat I'm turning
in my knees I thought having two skews
consoles was a mistake yeah I think the
developers like it does it matter my
daughter loves hers
I mean I don't know do they like it I
mean obviously it's more work but I
guess if their game is getting out to
more people because of their
proliferation of that console that's all
that matters right you want your game to
be everywhere as many places as possible
that's what you want so
then we got Bounty remember for one yeah
two dollar Super Chat I finally got a
chance to order something respect I
guess he ordered something from the Holy
Spirit y'all outside I see y'all
see mad five dollar Super Chat 1440p 60
FPS is the sweet spot for the average
consumer series s's affordability hits
that demographic Cloud then delivering
4K 120 FPS turns into an X so yes but
again you get a mid gen refresh it could
be closer to an X at the same price
point that's the thing price point is
key then we got chill Walker member for
one year five dollar Super Chat scoring
recent gameplay video was very
interesting I got to see what's going on
with this stuff on that game dripping
fallacies I don't know I don't see we
got Hot Grits nine ten two dollars I
have 11 000 games on my deck don't tell
anybody
then we got free R Kelly two dollar
Super Chat Kojima is washed up oh yeah
now now that he's for the streets he's
watched them nobody either care about
Aqua demon now
all right then we have Sycamore 007 10
chat socket told Jim no more dry
snitching get your team ready we coming
for you
and then we got hard to get to meet five
dollars for chat well one of
PlayStation's new attempts at Live
service game is down babylon's fall fell
good luck on the next one of those games
I mean it's Square Enix and it was I
mean we have it it's on Xbox isn't it
yeah it is no no
it's not on Xbox not on Xbox
it wasn't on the multiplayer yeah we'll
talk about that in a second oh but yeah
that's it we all caught up final topic
and I don't know if Eric want me to set
it up for him yeah I can't remember what
my talking was
shout out to team ninja man they out
here shout out to mpfirst.com I want to
salute them and of course
um next-gen player who follows me on
Twitter he conducted the interview with
Team Ninja at TGs uh 2022 and wo long
producer I put a butcher this for Mexico
yasada director of Neil to explain why
they said yes to Microsoft hosting the
game on Xbox game pass when it launches
so the question was what long is going
to be Day One on Game Pass what made the
team want to go the Game Pass route and
how if it has already benefited the team
usada said this is a first for us being
Day One on Game Pass while we making a
really really hard game we're not sure
what everyone would think of that but by
making it Day One on Game Pass for many
players that may never play this game
before will have a chance to do that and
we'll get even more players around the
world than ever before so yes this was a
big first for us at Kobe technical games
and team ninja as well and it's
something we're really excited about we
really think it would be great for the
most multiplayer with so many people to
play with and really increase the number
of people you have available to join
your party and take on bosses so we know
the demo is out now interesting comment
making the rounds so Lord addict this is
your topic what are your thoughts on
this
it's cool it's good for the game it's
definitely good for us the consumers
um you know I just
my big thing I just got to see what the
game is you know I do feel like
there has been some some misses that's
winning game pass over the past year and
I want to see you know some more hits
going to there and I think this game's
going to do well yeah you you were a big
fan of this game when I we asked you
like you seem like you were very high on
it on the demo yeah yeah I think uh I
think it's going to be good I just gotta
you know sometimes those demos can be a
little deceiving I don't think this is
one of those but sometimes they they
package up a good three hours of the
game and it's like the best game stuff
in the whole world
and you think that oh you know it's just
gonna get up from here no no it's not
like
without no doubt
Asante what are you thinking about these
statements from Team ninja and Game Pass
oh I'm just happy team ninjas back in
before us you know um I contend that
team ninja was from sophist for from
software [ __ ] that talk OG yeah you're
right you know like you know it's funny
you know a funny case I've been working
on a video and uh I was really playing
OJ RPGs and I came across a game called
enchanted Arms that's me oh yeah from
the software
a lot of people don't know that that
game is made from from by from software
that's right yeah yeah yeah and you know
and I've been a you know as as we've
already discussed I enjoyed my OG Xbox
One experience and you know from uh what
do you call it team ninja very much
instrumental in the in that time frame
did they were the Insomniac of the Xbox
OG Xbox one right they had mad you know
uh gained on that system you know the
ninja guidance that really you know
established something and of course the
the the the the that franchise has kind
of waned in in recent years you know the
newer iterations aren't as good but you
know team ninja established themselves
you know graphically and and and
gameplay wise they've been strong for
many years so for me personally it's
been kind of unfortunate that as 360 got
heavy and Xbox One got heavy they seemed
to be a little less than out front with
it you know what I'm saying like and
from soft kind of came came in and
obviously no no no uh taking nothing
away from them they've really
established themselves as a great as a
great uh gameplay and Atmospheric kind
of a developer but you know to see what
they're doing here and and I'm looking
at at what they're doing also rise of
the rodents also looks like it's gonna
be yeah it looks nice I'm looking
forward to playing that on PS5 so you
know for me this this story just is just
by and large I'm happy Tim Ninja's back
I want more from them I want them to
give from soft a run for their money
because as much as I like from soft and
I really do there are certain places
that they lack and because that game
like blew up the world I'm afraid that
writers are not going to get any more
work
you know I want I want there to be
competition and that's one part of the
thing where as much as I loved from Saul
and I heard that you know I heard that
uh R.R Martin was going he handed them a
couple a couple titles of some monsters
and kept it moving you know yeah he just
it was a very basic overview of like it
wasn't yeah it wasn't like this this
deep lore breakdown he gave them a basic
overview of of kind of what the world is
and they filled in the blanks and they
filled in the blanks exactly and now we
have uh we have Eldon being the biggest
thing on earth and the story is kind of
like
yeah
it makes me fear that since the the the
this environment and this this industry
looks at each other you know oh they
found the new the new formula that
formula May equal a lot of job loss for
people who like stories you know so I'm
kind of like come on that's happening
so team ninja has always been about the
stories whether the stories they
sometimes go Kojima crazy but they still
about the stories so I'm hoping that
team ninja comes back and also finds
success with that style of game so that
we can see you know as a community that
it's not just the from way with the
Obscure fingers
your fingers and the non-stories you
know yeah there's a lot of abstract
storytelling and storytelling and uh I'm
excited to see Tim ninja back in full
force you know maybe you leave your
maybe leave your your uh you know your
volleyball days behind you a little bit
might not necessarily be the best in
today's world but you know I'm happy to
see him back
I see what you're doing
my wonderful life in prison five dollars
free R Kelly told me to check y'all out
yeah
what is boy it's cool to listen to it's
cool to listen to while me and Kell to
some toilet wine before afterwards
yo yo that's crazy
you know what that probably is yeah I
think there's like three or four people
in our chat that keep changing their
name to make stuff that's probably the
same dude that changed his name the
white attic
I'm glad that our show was transcended
yo
walls that you know that they were
entertaining the the gentlemen you know
wrongfully incarcerated everybody's
wrongfully
to provide that that Comfort to those
entertainment you know you know
precarious situations you know saying we
we respect that while you're doing your
time brother you know what I'm saying
man my wonderful life in prison I would
watch at R Kelly if I was you I just
want to make sure R Kelly will be
available after this
anyway moving on so yeah so my take on
the team Ninja the game pass thing um
yeah man at Team ninja again they've
sort of been building towards this for a
while right obviously you see you know
they stepped up big time like another
level when ninja guy didn't hit the
original Xbox it one hands down one of
the greatest action games ever made and
then you know as we start seeing the
from formula sort of make its way into
gaming they made Neo
um and they started sort of going that
route a little bit and and for me it was
like okay if they're gonna continue down
that route why not make a game that
touches upon everything that they're
good at with with the fast action the
Neo style gameplay where it's a lot of
it unlike from right from you you do
have a lot of magic and stuff like that
but the the neo-type games is really
about like flashy magic and crazy stuff
going on
um so to see what long I played all
along for about two or three hours and I
really enjoyed it and because I felt
like I had it wasn't an open world per
se but I did feel like I had a lot of
options when it came to combat I didn't
have to just stand there and you know
and I had it it wasn't to the extent of
the of Neo when you had all these
different stances to do different stuff
but you did have some of that so it was
like the perfect Middle Ground yeah of
what you'd expect from a from game and
what you expect from what they've been
doing up until that point so that the
multiplayer stuff is just interesting
because again Game Pass has that
advantage over what over PlayStation
wears you're gonna want that you want
don't want that that that sort of fan
base already ingrained uh so you can
have that you know that special
multiplayer experience that you probably
won't be able to have on the PlayStation
and then the Game Pass thing obviously
you're gonna have so many eyes on it
that day one that the vision for what
they want that game to be is going to be
best realized doing something like that
on Game Pass now
in terms of what this means for their
games moving forward it's interesting
because you look at rise of the Ronin on
on Playstation that's very very much a
PlayStation s game right we haven't
heard about any multiplayer stuff but
you look at it and it looks like a
single player uh cinematic Samurai Story
game right
um but with PlayStation doing more to
sort of you know the service based games
expanding upon their service
and that warlong still coming to
Playstation I wonder what that means for
how how these games are perceived across
the board and and if that opens up the
door for for games like you know the
rise of the road in the coming Xbox
obviously PlayStation is partially
paying for this so that's probably never
gonna happen but future games where it's
like okay now the playing field is
leveled right because the thing is I
still have this thing where I think a
lot of these Japanese companies despite
the growing relationships they have with
Xbox it's still this thing where you
gravitate the PlayStation because that
base is there absolutely you know the
the people that play that those consoles
and expect a certain type of game right
um so to me
if this is successful on game passwords
I think it will be I think a lot of
people just going to gravitate to this
because we haven't seen this before on
Game Pass on Xbox in a long time right
so
um I just I just wonder if that opens
the thinking to hey everything
it everything is viable on all platforms
and maybe keep some from in the future
making more of these these exclusive
deals because I look at rise of the
Ronin and I'm like damn like I Roll
Along is great but again the multiplayer
aspect is a big deal to them although
you can play it single player was fine I
ain't gonna lie to you man after the
game over here
seeing the rolling thing just maybe like
Microsoft man you should have dropped
that bag and and make that game
exclusive but the question yeah oh yeah
to make it exclusive and make it like
this Xbox thing but again it's only got
no problem dropping that bag off at Team
ninja making stuff exclusive for this we
talking we talk about ideas and how
they're they're in exactly the same
ideas yeah ideals where they're in
exactly the same boat one is a yacht and
one is a dinghy and that's just that's
the difference it also it takes for any
deal it takes two people to accept right
yes we have to be clear you can want
something but if the other person does
not agree and feel it's viable for what
they're trying to do that's what it is
I'll jump in if you let you finish off
yeah I'm done I think the viability and
how well this does speaks to what we'll
see from them on Xbox in the future no
absolutely I thought this was very
interesting first of all you know this
is a huge get I don't want to minimize
for uh Xbox game pass getting a game
like well long into it I like to know
get behind the curtains and see okay how
did this come to be what were the
conditions that made this happen and
it's clear you know from what the
statement was saying like yo like they
they really value for this title that's
going to have a multiplayer component
right when you come in help me fight the
bosses you know something Elder ring
failed to do successfully in a seamless
fashion and I'm standing on that square
for people who defend this because in in
2022 we can't correctly link up with
your friends list and I gotta throw up a
bloody figure and do all time
oh no I saw the integration though on
the actual because not available in the
demo so it's yeah I don't know how it
works yeah absolutely but I will say
based on the interface and how clean and
easy and and recognizable it was for me
to say oh this is where you go connect
to someone which I couldn't do at
elderly which was not available I could
already see it's already a step ahead
now it's just a matter of the
integration my thing is I look at what
they're saying and I say okay that is
this may be one way for them to call a
trojan horse them weigh in as far as
these Japanese developers as far as
multiplayer engagement and number and
the fact that we got to think about the
other side the fact that team ninja saw
a value in Game Pass is interesting to
me you know I'm saying so clearly the
numbers are enough and them to say all
right you know what we'll put this title
on that now to addicts point and I do
feel what he's saying I think it's about
a bag as far as well it could be but I I
don't know I don't I don't have the
number I'm not privy to that all I'm
going to say is to add exploit it
reference to like a game like rise of
the Ronin it may very well be a say look
this is a single player game with no
multi-player component historically
Nintendo and Sony these type of games do
well on that service right I mean on
their platforms right right and we may
need to see long term if these type of
games would work and that that's a
relationship that has to get built over
time I just think that is because at the
end of the day the company has to do
what's best for them first same thing
with Square Enix same with it at the end
of the day they have to look at the
projections and say okay where would we
sell the most and what if if they do
offer a Game Pass bag and maybe again I
don't buy privileges information team
Ninja's number maybe
exceedingly high for biking off is for
them to meet in the middle and maybe
that's why these deals didn't get done
I'm not sure I'm not saying I'm into
this information yeah
I think that's
Sony probably helped fund a lot of that
running game that's oh yeah I mean it's
a second party game yeah definitely you
see that they're they're publishing it
so you know they're going to pay for all
the marketing all the influencing thing
going into it and team ninja is not like
a big Studio or anything like that I
don't think they're really they they
work with other Studios but you know
when you're coming up there just the
marketing loans probably worth them
making that exclusive and that exclusive
so yeah there's a lot of questions do we
think because of that we will never see
it on an Xbox platform and I asked that
question because of Tomb Raider Ronin
that specific question because of Tomb
Raider and it's seemingly the exact
opposite of where you know this time
it's PlayStation versus Xbox I think
there's no world where after it's all
said and done you can end up on just
just I think it'll go to PC I don't know
about Xbox yeah I don't know about
Xboxes it seems like here recently it
seems like when for the most part when
stuff hits that PlayStation platform
they don't leave that but it don't come
to another platform to me it's the time
of development and
and I have to look at when that game was
developed right because if it was the
development was started
during an Xbox one generation
bro you ain't getting that so to me I
think it's I look at a lot of this stuff
with building blocks and a lot a lot of
people don't want to hear this stuff
takes time it takes time to turn your
reputation around as a platform as a
platform to even consider this is not an
overnight thing and it's not to me well
oh they just ain't spend enough bread
people have to agree people have to look
at your platform as viability and what
I'm saying sovereign's point you know
the dinghy turns faster than the yacht
exactly
at the end of the day right now I'm
seeing they are intrigued right now by
getting fast they are intrigued by the
multi-player aspect of Gamepad and the
last thing I'll say on the double Focus
I know we got crazy law is that what I
think game passes next level for them to
get where they need to be is the third
party day and date yeah that to me is
what separate that to me because we you
know the first part he's coming and we
know what we already exist to have a
Halo infinite Forza motors for all these
gay Psychonauts Asia day one what you're
saying is when you hear one day that
they convinced like somebody like
Ubisoft to put a game for like caliber
game right day in day right into into
Game Pass it's a wrap after that and
that's why I don't want to minimize well
long though like drawing long is a huge
deal it's a huge deal we cannot minimize
lies of P
huge deal
The Tide is slowly changing atomic heart
yeah atomic heart day in day we're
starting to see it so it's like I got it
I think you gotta guess so no no no
you're absolutely right I think the
thing is also that sometimes when you
look at Game Pass right we always look
at game passes like oh it's the greatest
thing ever right but in a lot of ways it
could be somewhat of a hindrance for
them when it comes to those deals
because you know you've heard you've
heard you heard Deb say it like
monetarily it doesn't work for us up
front on the back end it'll work for us
sure to keep to keep the the game alive
right but on the front end maybe not
right right and when you think about how
Xbox makes steals the grand major the
vast majority of deals they're going to
make are for a game going the game plus
there's very few that are going to make
for exclusivity correct not Game Pass
exclusivity Phil himself said they're
really out of the exclusivity Market
it's the The Game Pass that's more value
to them yeah and the last point I'll say
is that like you see you see in that
growth whatever and then I look at it
like okay that has turned now when
that's why the Activision Blizzard kick
is so important
because when you get the influx of new
subscribers who will come for those
games that Call of Duty alone and now
you beef that now you come back to the
table and say look these are our active
subscriber numbers now you know we have
double triple whatever that 30 million
whatever it is right and now you come
back this 60 Minutes 80 minutes there's
a hundred minutes now the conversation
gets different right because you could
be like okay if we put this then they
look at all this engagement we're gonna
get if you got micro transactions in
your game whatever it is a DLC is a
different level and the conversation
gets better in Microsoft's position of
strength get better but to your points
off I will say that I do feel right now
some third-party companies are kind of
like a wait and see we'll get our money
on the front end by going to the the
shore fire things of the Sony and the
Nintendo first right then get the back
end on The Game Pass where the Zeitgeist
goes down to sit retail and whatever
second hit exact that second hit and I
think that's what Square Enix is doing
but that's just me but at the end of the
day it's good to see them now at least
breaking ground with day in day third
party like I said Eliza P the the whoa
Longs obviously we've seen it with the
outriders the city with the MLB the Show
we're starting to see you know what I'm
saying them kind of attach themselves to
day and day third party that that to me
is when I think it goes to the next
level that's what I want to see but
anyway that's pretty much all I got
unless anyone's got anything else on
that and uh we're gonna get this pole
with it you wanna get the super chassis
yeah get the pool first and I have a
couple to copy in right now that just
came in all right no doubt no doubt uh
new IPO with the recent statements by
Microsoft CEO Satya Nadella in regards
to competition with sodi in the midst of
the Activision Blizzard King deal
scrutiny what do you think Sony's
response should be the choices are a
continue to reference The Regulators the
ramifications of car not having an
adequate deal for PlayStation Gamers to
Block
B get Microsoft to commit to a long-term
deal regarding Cod parody on PlayStation
or see I don't care ask Nintendo how
they survive it without Cod on the
switch
shout out to all those on the pole
that's been rocking and rolling please
hit that up and of course we have to
salute the legendary K asati rocking us
through the marathon of IOP that it is
today that it is that it is everywhere
every week
man I'm here I appreciate it being much
better I appreciate you brother you
don't say where can I find people find
you what you got going on Sir oh well I
will first and foremost say thank you
thank you so much for having me on this
is this has been this is I don't know I
asked my wife what's next
I'm done now
thank you guys so much this is awesome
you know I'm I'm always in the chat I'm
a huge fan I'm going to continue to be a
fan it's awesome and you know the way
you folks uh the way you the camaraderie
you know the energy every Sunday I I
think I speak for everyone in that chat
and say you know you give us energy and
you keep us going and we appreciate you
so hopefully we'll keep you all y'all
keep going and keep getting better but
for me it's TKO Asante on Twitter Xbox
PlayStation all the places you want to
find me I won't give you my Social
Security number so you can't find me on
this no switch
I am the co-host of the gaming Circle
podcast
normally normally we're a podcast that
we we like to give you some news some
some music some some movies and all that
stuff with a little bit of slander as
well you know and and just to get you
get you started on your Saturday that is
10 a.m Eastern Standard Time with myself
and Mr ever born Saga which I'm sure
you've seen on this great program before
yes but yes again thank you thank you so
much it has been awesome you know Lord
addict Lord Sovereign and and Cognito of
course Lord king is not here right now
always follow you guys think it's
absolutely awesome that that you guys
continue doing the great work you do and
and and we will always be in the chat
support thank you brother thank you man
love what you bring to the game yo make
sure y'all hit up the ksrt YouTube
channel and put the links in the chat go
subscribe man let's get these brothers
over to at least a thousand scrubs they
Subs they're killing it they're doing
their thing well I love what you bring
to the game to balanced attack you know
what I'm saying and it's always
insightful you know what I'm saying and
respect and a lot of good conspiracy
theories yes a good conspiracy and great
great technology tinkering
salute to you really love what you're
doing man I'm glad we got this now this
is an absolutely fun show man I loved
every minute of it no doubt lucious guys
where to pull the poser on Twitter sir
it's the post on Twitter I know we're
changing we're going away from blognit
on that and we're doing our thing so
Twitter is there because we felt there
with some social engineering happening
roll out all right so we have one bad
Bubba remember for two years five
dollars great to see Captain keys on
today's show
yeah I hope we can convince Master Chief
to keep his pants on and she's a two
great show Friends
OBM Brothers No cheeks no cheeks no
master
cheeksis
then we got shroom Kingdom two dollars
Super Chat member for one year Miss
Super Chat and love you guys still
listening man uh listen just being here
is what matters brother that's all man
yeah
absolutely then we got PO with an Mo a
ten dollar Super Chat Robert didn't I
revoke your internet privileges after
you were dming Disney stars again wow
by the way Cog great show let us know
when you got some more info for us we'll
have some fresh Popeyes for you
not the snitching cups
I know
I played the warlong demo co-op with a
friend and you can play the entire demo
together and it's easy and intuitive
unlike Elden ring it's great who said
that who said that that was Donald
tackle my man Donald Taco thank you I
already knew it was going to be better
but I just had to be political I mean it
doesn't take much to be better
just checking in great chat thank you
brother thank you then we got blame
remember for one year two dollar Super
Chat I agree with R Kelly regarding
Kojima hashtag wash wow I don't do that
don't do that too much like that that's
it we're caught up
where can I find people find you what
you got going on sir
you can find me on Twitter at Lord
addict IOP you can find me on YouTube at
gaming addict or thank Our Guest for
coming on it was a great time sorry I've
been up and down I haven't been feeling
the greatest today you stayed through I
know he wasn't feeling well brother yeah
well I was sitting I was like uh yeah
I guess I just pushed through it
I appreciate it for coming through man
we add up to I think almost 800 people
in here you gotta show up every week
yeah hit that like button let's get that
over 600 man let's get over 600. yeah
we're doing a podcast next week
but I appreciate it for coming through
man uh you know we got some stuff coming
up for you uh you know Tech talk is is a
pretty big push right now so we'll
definitely go uh follow us on Tick Tock
if you guys want to I don't know how
many of these people in here have a tick
tock but I'll put it in the chat if you
do put that Tick Tock link again man we
tick-tocking out here and it's like I
said you know we we do for those of you
that saw the community day yesterday uh
we're gonna try now how it's gonna go is
we're gonna have goals every month uh
for the podcast and every time you hit a
go you'll get something extra for the
Lords and uh that Community stream will
be one of them we will be doing more of
those just depending on what happens
throughout the month and you know try to
try to do it every month if we can
obviously that's not something that we
can commit to uh because people still
got jobs so you know I appreciate
everyone for coming through we're going
to be trying to go to more events we're
actually trying to go to the uh the
Video Game Awards uh you know uh so for
able to go there don't expect a uh a
podcast that a week but you know what
you can expect some coverage
if we're able to go you can expect to
see Attic in a suit and tie yeah
yeah that's the protocol let's go there
must be a patreon
it got different
you know it's like Cox said like we you
always think your story is so unique
stuff all we only we was doing this
craziness to get our gaming on and the
fact of the matter is that's what I love
about people coming on here and giving
their stories because you find so many
similarities and differences right but
you see the extent when we talk about
we're in here and we're playing these
games for the past 30 40 years when you
love game Loving video games it's a very
distinct and special thing yes and I
think more than any other hobby it is it
is this thing that you share with so
many people and back then we only shared
it with a small group like it's just a
couple of us and that that was your
group and now to see like
I just love hearing your story man and
the fact that again it all brings us
back to where we are now so I love it I
love it keep doing what you're doing you
know I I I you know ever born I love me
some other boy and I love him even more
when I get the means but yes yeah oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah I got y'all yes oh
yeah yeah no but again I I say I would
love to give them these up if they do
that I will be here with little butter
on my knees I will do that I'm waiting
for I'm waiting for Sony to buy them
just just to see what everyone does oh
no that'll be crazy
[Laughter]
that's it no doubt no doubt and of
course you don't even salute to this I
don't know why my camera just zoomed up
for no rare reason but okay whatever
um salute to a King man coming through
doing his thing you know what I'm saying
so today I'm giving his bars off and
again salute to ksrt that was ton of fun
had some great stories and I'll also
like it to um hip-hop in a way because
it's like sometimes you think it's this
little thing that you love and then you
see how it's growing in the gaming
you're going to see it's just absolutely
amazing to see where gaming has come so
salute everybody in the chat that's all
I got anything else addict or we good
yes we're good all right no doubt
everybody enjoying Sunday we will see
you Peach
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]